mesdames Messieurs chers collègues nous
devions entendre ce matin le directeur
général des outrmèes Monsieur Olivier
Jacob qui a succédé en août dernier à
Madame Sophie brocass resté 3 ans à ce
poste celui-ci est empêché compte tenu
de son déplacement à la Réunion à la
suite de l'ouragan Béal c'est Madame
Karine de la marche adjointe au
directeur général des aut maires qui le
remplac nous vous remercions euh
vivement d'avoir pu le remplacer au
piedlev vous êtes accompagné de madame
Isabelle Richard sous-directrice des
politiques publiques de Monsieur Olivier
Benoît sous-directeur des affaires
juridiqu et institutionnel vous êtes
aussi entouré des
ambassadeurs nommés pour les trois
bassins
océaniques pour nos travaux concernant
nos travaux donc Monsieur Jean-Claude
Brunet ambassadeur délégal la
coopération régionale dans la zone de
l'océan Indien Monsieur Roland dubertan
ambassadeur chargé de la coopération
régionale dans la dans la zone
atlantique et nous devions avoir en
vision Madame Véronique Roger Lacan qui
malheureusement n'a pas encore pu nous
rejoindre à cause des difficultés
techniques elle est représentante
permanente de la France auprès de la
communauté du Pacifique et du programme
régional de l'environnement madame la
actrice même si cela n'était pas prévu
vous pourrez si vous le souhaitez nous
éclairer sur l'ampleur de la catastrophe
qui touche aussi l'île voisine de
Maurice et les moyens mises en œuvre
c'est aussi
l'occasion de redire à nos concitoyens
réunionné toute notre solidarité face
aux épreuves qu'ils affrontent en fait
nous avions pris contact il y a
plusieurs semaines déjà euh avec la dgom
parce que la délégation a décidé de
travailler sur deux thèmes d'études euh
le premier concerne l'adaptation des
moyens d'action de l'État dans les
outremerses le 2è la coopération et
l'intégration régionale des outresmèes
euh qui sera l'objet de la
première de la première réunion
concernant le déroulé de cette réunion
donc nous rejoindrons plus tard Monsieur
Victor Lurel corapporteur et et Philippe
bass sur les moyens de de l'État et nous
commencerons donc par la coopération
régionale sur pour laquelle nous avons
nommé un rapporteur coordonnateur
Monsieur Christian coman qui
s'excuse qu'il nous regarde en direct
puisqu'il est coincé dans son
département à cause de l'épisode néjeux
que nous avons connu cette nuit pour le
bassin Pacifique madame Éveline Corbier
naminzo et Monsieur Rachid temmal qui
s'excuse aussi pour les mêmes raisons
dans le bassin Atlantique TVAR FR et
Jacqueline Hustache brigot et pour le
bassin indien monsieur George passion
qui est en visio et Monsieur Stéphane
demillet donc contenu des nombreux
sujets à aborder je vais vous céder la
parole sans plus tarder pour vos propos
liminire vous pourrez aussi vous
inspirer de la trame qui vous a été
adressée pour préparer la réunion et
demander aussi à à vos équipes et nos
ambassadeurs de nous préciser un certain
nombre de points et puis nous n céderons
après la parole à
nos rapporteurs pour des remarques et
des questions
complémentaires merci madame la
Présidente donc je voulais réétirer
par merci madame la Présidente je
voulais réétirer les excuses d'Olivier
Jacob donc il accompagnait à la réunion
le ministre de l'Intérieur
et
suite au cyclone son avion a eu
plusieurs heures de retard et il vient
d'atterrir et donc il ne pourra nous
rejoindre dans les temps vous m'invitiez
à faire un petit point de situation
suite au cyclone Béal
euh qui euh maintenant euh est est moins
s'éloigne de la de la Réunion
euh la situation est sous maîtrise en
revanche il y a de très très nombreux
dégâts euh heureusement peu de perte
humaine euh mais de très nombreux de
gals la solidarité nationale a bien
évidemment joué
euh des renforts sont venus depuis
l'hexagone depuis Mayotte également euh
et à présent il va falloir entamer la
phase de reconstruction et pour cela le
ministère des outremèes notamment mais
aussi d'autres ministères mettront en
place les outils pour venir en aide à
toutes les victimes et aux collectivités
pour réparer leurs dégâts on a un outil
outreem qui s'appelle le fond de secours
outreem qui va être déployé très vite
vis-à-vis des collec activité et très
vite vis-à-vis des entreprises agricoles
notamment voilà pour pour pour pour le
point à la Réunion la la la situation
doit toujours être observée pour pour
être sûr que on en a bien fini avec ce
cyclone
euh voilà j'en reviens à notre à notre
intervention au thème de votre étude sur
la la coopération régionale comme vous
l'avez indiqué nous nous sommes nous
sommes CIN à représenter la direction
des outremèes donc ce que je vous
propose c'est de faire peut-être un
panorama général et ensuite j'ai compris
que votre étude se situait bassin par
bassin et donc je donnerai la parole aux
ambassadeurs la DG hom ayant la chance
d'avoir des ambassadeurs en son sein qui
pourront vous donner un un zoom du coup
sur l'Atlantique comme sur l'océan
Indien sur sur le fond je crois que nous
partageons les premiers
constats que vous avez fait c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a un degré insuffisant de
développement de la coopération
régionale et bien évidemment cont tenu
de ce constat la nécessité de la
développer pour contribuer au
développement économique des territoires
un constat également partagé sur le fait
que cette coopération peut-être un outil
de lutte contre la vie chère en revanche
je nuancerai immédiatement après pour
dire que si c'est un outil c'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga il y a beaucoup
d'autres paramètres qui rentrent dans la
chireté de la
vie peut-être un rappel vous le savez
mais la France avec ses outres mères a
une une chance
formidable et une place singulière au
sein de l'Europe c'est le seul pays
membre à avoir à la fois des régions
ultra périphériques et des
PTOM c'est le seul pays à avoir des
frontières sur les trois bassins euh et
ça nous oblige mais ça c'est une une
vraie chance il y a des enjeux
stratégiques sur ce positionnement ce
sont des éléments clés de la défense de
la politique de défense française c'est
également des éléments clés en matière
économique grâce à la zone économique
exclusive et puis tout ça appelle des
des enjeux de sécurisation et c'est
également un élément clé pour les nos
outremèes qui doit
pouvoir avoir des relations aussi
fluides
et et riches que possible avec leur
environnement
régional donc compte tenu de de la
présence de la France sur sur ces trois
océans la coopération régionale est bien
évidemment l'une des
priorités à laquelle s'emploie au
quotidien le ministère des outrem avec
ses partenaires he le ministère des
Affaires étrangères et de l'Europe au
premier chef et et parce que c'est un
levier des territoires ultramarins vous
nous avez interrogé
sur le degré d'insertion régionale alors
malheureusement nous n'avons pas d'étude
totalement exhaustive sur le sujet avec
une même méthodologie mais nous avons
les instituts d'émission des outrmèes
qui font des études régulières sur sur
ce point le constat lorsqu'on lorsqu'on
regarde le niveau de développement
économique c'est que bien évidemment
nous avons une insertion perfectible
lorsqu'on regarde les échanges
commerciaux qui sont à la fois faibles
et déséquilibré au-delà de l'hexagone et
de l'Union européenne des exportations
qui se caractérisent qui sont très
concentré sur quelques production
singulière et importante et puis des
économies qui quelquefois manquent
d'avantage comparatif vis-à-vis de l'UR
environnement très proche qui peut avoir
un niveau de développement bien
inférieur et qui en terme de compétition
économique et et de normes également et
de protection n'ont pas tout à fait les
mêmes standards c'est pour ça que pour
faciliter l'insertion régionale la dgum
déploie des moyens pour permettre la
création de valeur dans les territoires
et accompagner les entreprises mais
aussi
pour promouvoir l'installation dans les
outremèes des des
entreprises la coopération régionale est
également une priorité dès lors qu'elle
peut contribuer à lutter contre la vie
chère je je le disais en quelques mots
et ce même si les déterminants de ce
phénomène sont plus complexes par
exemple on pourrait se dire qu'en
théorie avoir plus d'importation à
moindre coût
permettrait de solutionner la vie chère
mais simplement une partie des frais
d'approche des approv isionnement est
quasiment forfaitaire donc on on
gagnerait un petit peu mais il faut bien
penser à ce coup de frite peut même être
quelqufis plus cher dans l'environnement
proche que depuis l'hexagone cont tenu
de la massification des flux c'est
encore une économie à travailler mais en
tout cas aujourd'hui euh ça peut sembler
contreintuitif mais on on a cela ensuite
on a pour la protection des
consommateurs un enjeu très fort
puisqueaujourd'hui euh l'ensemble des
consommateurs ultramarins bénéficie de
la protection et des normes Union
européenne donc ces importations dans
l'environnement proche oui mais à
équivalence de norm et à équivalence de
protection pour pour les pour les
consommateurs et c'est pour ça que
l'action du ministère des outresmers
pour l'importation dans dans la zone est
ciblé sur des produits dont les prix
sont significativement plus bas euh et
puis euh dont les normes sont
équivalentes j'ajoute à cela une un un
dernier élément à prendre en en compte
euh compte tenu des niveaux de
développement hétérogène dans chacune
des zones il y a aussi un enjeu de
protection des des productions
locales enfin sur la sur les normes euh
les autorités françaises veillent à la
prise en compte des spécificités des
régions ultramarines euh dans le cadre
des négociations européennes euh nous
avons un article 349 dans le traité qui
permet d'avoir des adaptations euh aux
spécificités des rupes donc euh les
autorités françaises tentent de le
rendre effectif euh et cet objectif a
été euh réaffirmé en novembre dernier
euh sur l'avenir de la politique de
cohésion euh et nous avons obtenu sur
proposition de la délégation française
qu'à présent l'ensemble de la
réglementation européenne euh comporte
une étude
d'impact sur l'effet de de de ces normes
sur les rupes un autre exemple
emblématique de d'adaptation des normes
qui est d'actualité c'est la révision de
la réglementation relative au matériaux
de construction qui était qui est une
demande euh inscrite depuis longtemps et
porté par l'ensemble des élus d'outremer
et donc nous aurons bientôt la
possibilité d'éroger à l'obligation de
Mar de marquage pardon Union européenne
pour permettre un marquage Rupe euh en
terme de calendrier euh nous avons eu le
trilogue a adopté le texte en décembre
dernier et on devrait avoir le règlement
qui fera l'objet d'une d'une d'une
adoption formelle et si le Parlement
pouvait voter la disposition avant les
élections nous entamer ons nous les
travaux pour préparer les textes
réglementaires et rendre effectif cette
avancée cette
avancée autre autre action que nous que
nous
menons pour rappeler le réflex outremire
je vous en j'aurais peut-être l'occasion
d' d'en reparler lors de la seconde
audition c'est une instruction qu'on
proposera au Premier ministre pour
rappeler à l'ensemble des ministères de
prendre en compte la dimension
ultramarine de toutes les
négociation internationales qu'ils
conduisent quelquefois au travers des
négociations internationales la dgom
peut être un petit peu oublié et donc
nous leur rappellerons à quel point
c'est important
puisque les rupes notamment sont bien
présentes à nos côtés je terminerai mon
propos un peu long pardon par quelques
élément sur l'action menée pour
développer une diplomatie commune avec
les territoires ultramarins euh tout
d'abord euh euh à la suite de la loi
notre euh de nouvelles compétences ont
été données aux collectivité et nous
avons déployé pour accompagner ces
compétences depuis 2016 des conseillers
diplomatiques auprèf auprès des des des
préfets de région euh ce réseau est
n'est pas encore totalement achevé il
reste quelques conseillers diplomatiques
à installer euh mais en tout cas c'est
bien
lancé nous avons également euh une
action en cours euh mes mes collègues
ambassadeurs pourront y revenir plus
précisément sur des stratégies
concertées par bassin donc entre l'État
et les collectivités qui est en cours de
finalisation simplement pour s'entendre
sur les priorités de notre action
commune à l'international
euh voilà et enfin nous avons également
une stratégie en cours sur les échanges
commerciaux des territoires euh de
l'océan Atlantique et de l'océan Indien
et l'enjeu ici de et d'identifier les
freins aux échanges et de mettre en
place une stratégie pour les les
fluidifier et les diversifier enfin en
parallèle dans la zone Pacifique puisque
les collectivités du Pacifique ont des
compétences très distinctes euh des des
autres collectivités ultramarines euh
nous nous finalisons quasiment j'espère
dans dans les jours à venir un guide
pratique à destination des collectivités
de la zone euh sur la extérieure de la
France pour les aider à s'emparer de ces
outils et à faire que la coopération
régionale soit pleinement effective
voilà madame la Présidente pour pour mes
propos si si vous en êtes d'accord et on
peut faire un éclairage par bassin en
tout cas sur sur les deux bassins qui
sont représentés
ici d'accord merci donc je vais je vais
prendre le relais en en quelques mots
euh en en introduction par rapport à à à
toutes les questions du du du
questionnaire moi je voudrais soulever
quatre points sur ces questions
d'intégration et d'insertion régionale
le premier c'est vrai que d'un point de
vue diplomatique il y a une une
revalorisation stratégique des des
outremèes alors ça ça a été lié d'abord
à la situation internationale he et aux
tensions qu'on connaît aujourd'hui le le
le la compétition entre les les
États-Unis et et la Chine et ça vaut
beaucoup pour mon voisin avec la zone
Indo-Pacifique mais ça a aussi des
répercussions sur l'Atlantique et sur la
la Caraïbe puisqueil y a également un
autre facteur qui touche tous les
outresmers c'est le fait que le le rôle
et les enjeux liés aux océans sont en
train de de monter ça ça concerne
évidemment aussi le le
l'Atlantique les États-Unis par exemple
ont lancé un un partenariat Atlantique
avec un certain nombre de de partenaire
dans la région donc il y a une
revalorisation stratégique ça c'est le
je crois le premier point le le deuxème
point c'est que depuis à peu près une
vingtaine d'années c'est les les postes
d'ambassadeur pour la coopération
régionale antiguyan devenu Atlantique
par le l'insertion de Saint-Pierre et
miolon et le poste d'ambassadeur chargé
de la coopération régionale Océan Indien
ont été créé en 2000 au moment de la loi
de de 2000 là donc on a maintenant un
peu de recul sachant que le poste
Pacifique lui est plus ancien puisqu'il
date des années 80 c'était un autre
notre format à l'époque mais ceci dit si
on prend les les 20 dernières années
avec une politique de l'État quand même
et des lois plus affirmé pour favoriser
l'insertion régionale hein des
collectivités desutres mè je vois que
dans la zone dont dont je m'occupe et en
particulier pour Antig Guyane c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu le le premier euh résultat
je dirais c'est qu'il y a eu une
véritable intégration dans les
organisations régionales hein la
Martinique et la Guadeloupe sont rentrés
dans
l'OEC Saint-Martin va bientôt rentrer
l'Eco la Martinique la Guadeloupe
Saint-Martin sont rentrés dans
l'association des États de la Caraïbe et
aujourd'hui le la dernière étape c'est
la caricome finalement parce que les les
collectivités n'étaient pas présentes
dans la la CARICOM qui est
l'organisation historique de la Caraïbe
la Guyane et la Martinique sont
candidates pour devenir membre associé
de la CARICOM donc il y a je dirais
qu'il y a un mouvement non seulement
pour rentrer dans les organisations
régionales mais après les collectivités
comme membres associés participent
jouent le jeu et participe aux actions
ça c'est un point important deuxième
point important et ça il faut le je
pense qu'il faut le
reconnaître les moyens de la coopération
régionale c'est beaucoup aujourd'hui
interreèg hein donc c'est le soutien
l'Union européenne dans la région on a
un programme Amazonie qui est géré par
la collectivité territoriale de Guyane
hein qui est l'autorité de gestion et
qui permet de développer des projets
structurants avec les états du nord du
Brésil le Suriname le Guyana et puis
vous avez un programme Caraïb qui est
géré par la Région Guadeloupe qui est
autorité de gestion qui associe les les
collectivités Martinique Saint-Martin et
saint-barelémi et qui est dirigé
vraiment sur la région caraïbe idem avec
un certain nombre de projets euh
structurants donc ça je pense que ce ce
rôle de de l'Union européenne il faut
vraiment l'avoir à à l'esprit hein c'est
quelque c'est quelque chose de de de
crucial il y a aussi du côté de l'État
le fond de coopération régionale hein
qui est placé auprès des préfectures
mais qui aujourd'hui aide plutôt des des
petits projets en réalité et puis
évidemment il y a aussi le l'activité
des les AC action des des collectivités
ell-mêm en en propre dernière remarque
c'est aussi un je pense c'est une
évolution de ces dernières années c'est
en coopération internationale en lien
entre l'État et les collectivités c'est
la montée des problèmes régaliens et les
problèmes de l'insécurité dans la
Caraïbe et des trafics hein alors je
pense que c'est évident pour trafic de
drogue et le trafic d'armes dans
l'ensemble
caribéen et puis vous avez après dans le
casadre de la guyan série de de menaces
et et de défis vous avez quand même
leorpayage illégal vous avez la pêche
illégal donc le le sénateur patient qui
est là connait parfaitement ses ses
sujets vous avez aussi les trafics de de
drogue
hein et d'autres donc si vous prenez le
cas de la Guyane il est clair que la
relation avec le Surinam et avec le
Brésil c'est crucial dans beaucoup de de
de domaines enfin quand même en particul
ul dans le domaine de la coopération de
de de sécurité he c'est d'abord une
compétence de l'État bien entendu mais
qui s'exerce au au profit des des
territoires c'est un sujet montant voilà
ce que je voulais
dire merci donc pour le l'océan Indien
et bonjour à toutes et à tous Tout
d'abord je
voudrais souligner aussi quelques points
de mon côté très similaire à vrai dire à
à ceux qui qui viennent
d'être présentés par mon collègue pour
Antig guuyan mais avec des
particularités tout de même bien bien
sûr sur la zone Océan
Indien et je voudrais en particulier
relever en effet comme cela a été dit
par Karine le march de la marche c'est
la notre action qui
s'inscrit
dans une double un double objectif de
promouvoir l'attractivité de nos
outrmers dans la zone de l'océan Indien
et de
d'intégrer leur capacité leur leurs
structures leur
leurs institutions leurs acteurs qui
sont directement dans la zone et
partenairire des pays de la région
d'intégrer le plus possible dans notre
politique étrangère et dans nos
objectifs stratégiqu et Karine de
laamarche a évoqué la stratégie
Indo-Pacifique dans la zone Océan Indien
nous sommes euh une zone une part
importante de cette zone Indo-Pacifique
et part importante donc de la stratégie
de la France et de l'Union européenne
donc avec les enjeux géostratégiques euh
mon collègue a parlé des des enjeux
régaliens 70 % du commerce entre l'Union
européenne et l'Asie passe par le trans
par le transport maritime par l'Océan
Indien euh et donc effectivement on a
des enjeux géostratégiques importants
Indo-Pacifique et nous bénéficions bien
sûr des atouts que nos outremèes
apportent dans la région et euh je veux
dire la la Réunion est un point
d'ancrage de notre politique étrangère
et de sécurité et de pilier pour notre
notre stratégie Indo-Pacifique euh avec
le 3è port militaire et et on a on a la
3è Z Z zone économique exclusive dans
l'océan Indien la 2uxème au niveau
mondial donc c'est effectivement une une
grande priorité
d'intégrer nos outres-mers dans ces
objectifs stratégiques et de travailler
également à au renforcement de leur
attractivité je voudrais mon deuxième
commentaire concerne euh
particulièrement aussi la donc l'Union
européenne a été mentionné et je voulais
également évoquer que nous sommes dans
l'océan Indien euh dans dans une
situation où nous pouvons effectivement
renforcer sensiblement la coordination
de nos de nos actions national nos
actions état outreem avec le fond de
coopération régionale mais où nous
pouvons aussi renforcer la coordination
entre les financements Interreg et là je
voudrais dire qu'il y a effectivement un
Interreg donc concernant la Réunion est
géré par la Réunion mais aussi un
Interreg pour
Mayotte et donc nous avons C ces
possibilités là en terme de financement
d'action et en plus donc les
financements européens très importants
dans la zone de l'océan Indien
particulièrement comme partenaire de la
France pour appuyer les organisations
régionales et ça c'est effectivement le
deuxième point que je voulais mentionner
très à ce à ce stade de notre discussion
c'est que nous
bénéficions de la présence de la France
à part entière comme membre plein si
vous voulez de deux organisations
régionales que sont donc la Commission
de l'Océan Indien à laquelle nous
participons depuis 1986 et et également
l'association des pays riverins de
l'Océan Indien donc les 23 pays de tout
le pourtour l'océan Indien dont nous
sommes membres pleins depuis 3 ans et
euh donc nous et j'ai mentionné
l'importance de travailler avec les les
institutions européennes parce que ces
deux organisations donc nous la
Commission de l'Océan Indien nous sommes
un partenaire important avec un
financement notamment de la de l'Agence
française de développement qui est qui
est le premier contributeur financier de
la de la COI mais l'Union européenne est
tout de suite après le 2e et
historiquement un soutien très fort de
des actions de la COI et la et l'Union
européenne est devenue partenaire de du
dialogue donc observateur de l'ORA donc
l'association des pays riverins de
l'Océan Indien dont je parlais à
l'instant et donc qui va l'Union
européenne va également financer un
certain nombre d'actions dans ce cadre
de l'ORA comme la France aussi à travers
l'AFD et dans ces deux organisations
donc les outremèes jouent un rôle en
particulier la la Réunion et
principalement la
Réunion on pourra évoquer bien sûr le
développement du potentiel de Mayot en
coopération régionale dans la région et
qui peut s'appuyer sur l'interreg que
j'ai évoqué euh et sur des atouts que
cette que cette collectivité a
également à à à faire valoir dans la
coopération mais donc ces deux
organisations régionales nous permettent
de couvrir en fait trois cercles euh
principaux géographiquement de priorités
dans la coopération régionale dans
l'océan Indien ce sont bien sûr tout
d'abord les les îles du sud-ouest dans
ce qu'on appelle l'Indian Océanie hein
donc de qui recouvre les îles du Sud
sud-ouest membre de la Commission de
l'Océan
Indien ça c'est le premier cercle
ensuite il y a les partenaires africains
les de la côte africaine de l'Est l'Est
africain et et de la l'Afrique australe
avec lesquels la Réunion et Mayot
coopère de plus en plus et 3ème cercle
c'est justement les pays riverins et
donc c'est là on est vraiment dans le
l'Indo-Pacifique puisque ce sont des
partenaires stratégiques comme l'Inde ou
l'Australie ou l'Indonésie euh autre
remarque que je voulais faire c'est que
pour se concentrer sur les atouts des
collectivités et des alors je je
voudrais indiquer aussi que nous
travaillons bien sûr avec la Réunion et
Mayotte mais aussi les Terres australes
et Antarctique française euh si les
réunions et mayottes sont des rupes des
régions ultrapériphériques de l'Union
européenne la les taf sont une un PTOM
d'ailleurs et donc les donc nous
travaillons euh sur des des atouts de de
chacune de ces de ces entités de ces
collectivités et évidemment la Réunion
est comme nous disons le vaisseau amiral
de la politique de la France dans dans
l'océan Indien mais les taf ont une
capacité de coopération scientifique il
y a eu des a une feuille de route qui a
été développée récemment avec
l'IRD pour une coopération scientifique
avec les partenaires de la région j'ai
évoqué bien sûr l'importance de la ze
euh et je voudrais dire aussi que donc
euh les euh nous avons on aura
l'occasion dans nos échanges peut-être
d'évoquer les des des projets
extrêmement prometteurs qui se
développent à partir des atouts des uns
et des autres euh la Réunion par exemple
est est vraiment euh initiatrice de de
de projets structurants dans le cadre de
l'iora donc avec nos partenaires indiens
indonésiens australiens que j'ai évoqué
sud-africain euh sur certains un certain
nombre de sujets et donc met en œuvre
euh pour pour la France euh la
politique donc de dans la stratégie
Indo-Pacifique euh et et et des
partenariat stratégique avec un un
certain nombre de partenaires dans la
région euh mais bien sûr dans la
Commission de l'Océan Indien où il y a
cette communauté de destin que nous
construisons dans le Sud-Ouest entre les
îles
euh qui don dont nos îles sont les
voisines et partenaires euh nous avons
des projets extrêmement structurants en
en cours et en développement et que nous
continuerons à soutenir euh et je
voudrais en mentionner deux notamment un
sur la santé c'est le programme Sega euh
une seule santé one health avec santé
humaine animale et l'impact
environnemental euh avec une une
structure à la fois opérationnelle de
gestion de crise en matière de santé de
surveillance épidémiologique qui a fait
ses preuves dans le contexte de la
covid-19 et qui continue euh son action
avec le soutien des partenaires et
notamment de la France et l'Union
européenne et le deuxème de programme
c'est en matière de sécurité et sûreté
maritime j'ai évoqué ces enjeux
géostratégiques et en fait la Commission
de l'Océan Indien avec notre appui et
celui de l'Union européenne est un un
partenaire pour mettre en œuvre dans le
contexte d'une politique européenne de
promotion de la sécurité maritime la
sûreté maritime en Afrique et dans le la
zone Océan Indien la la Commission de
l'Océan Indien va être donc est donc
l'opératrice de d'un programme qui
gère en particulier qui pilote deux
centres mutualisés un de de fusion
d'information euh opérationnel qui est
situé à Madagascar et l'autre de
coordination opérationnelle qui est
situé au céchel et et donc nous nous
avons un soutien renforcé nous France à
travers les affaires maritimes la Marine
nationale euh le ministère de l'Europe
les affaires étrangères avec la
coopération sécurité et défense eu euh
qui va poursuivre son appui à ce
programme mais c'est pour vous démontrer
par ces deux exemples effectivement que
la Commission de l'Océan Indien même si
effectivement comme Karine de la marche
l'a mentionné nous avons largement
encore un potentiel à développer dans
l'efficacité des des organisations
régionales nous avons par exemple pour
la Commission de l'Océan Indien ces deux
programmes extrêmement structurants et
prometteurs qui sont actuellement en
développement
voilàr
là merci messieur madame Richard vous
vous souhaitez ajouter quelque chose
donc je vais laisser la parole à nos
deux rapporteurs du bassin océan Indien
pour débuter puisque ce sont eux qui
c'est qui c'est l'océan Indien le bassin
Océan Indien qui qui débute ce cette
étude triénal et évidemment les autres
rapporteurs sont aussi invités à à poser
leurs
questions vous m'autorisez à à commencer
mesdames et messieurson bonjour et et
bonne année j'avais un C nombre de
questions à poser mais vous avez répondu
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur à certaines
d'entre elles dans dans dans votre
intervention je voudrais revenir sur les
les les propos de de Madame de la marche
dans son propos introductif vous avez
parlé de de la vie chère et c'était
d'ailleurs l'objet de de la deuxième
question du du questionnaire qui vous a
été adressé en France métropolitaine on
a eu une inflation de 4,9
cette année enfin l'année qui vient de
se terminer après avoir vécu une
inflation de de 5,2 % en
2022 et je viens de poser hier une
question au gouvernement par le B d'une
d'une question écrite
sur le le le ressenti et le réel sa
qu'on a importé du Canada il y a
quelques années donc la la météo réelle
et la météo ressenti et je trouve que
pour l'inflation on est en train de
vivre un peu la même chose c'estàd qu'il
y a les chiffres officiels qui sont
annoncés par l'INC et puis il y a le le
le ressenti de de de nos populations et
et en décortiquant d'ailleurs le le le
panier qui est qui des éléments qui sont
pris en considération pour calculer le
le taux de l'inflation j'ai un peu le
sentiment que on est un peu à côté de la
réalité qu'il va falloir repenser le le
le panier de l'INC alors suite à à ce
propos introductif monsieur Brunet je me
disais est-ce que il y a également un
ressenti différent au niveau de de de
l'inflation notamment donc dans dans
l'océan Indien je pense en particulier à
la Réunion à Mayotte d'abord un quel est
le taux officiel donc est-ce qu'il y a
un taux officiel au niveau de de ces de
ces départements et puis deuxièmement
quel est comment réagisse la comment
réagit la population par rapport à à ce
ressenti de de l'inflation et parce que
la notion de lutte contre la vie chère
est vraiment une notion qui est de plus
importante de plus en plus importante
chez nous ici en métropole mais je pense
également donc dans dans les territoires
ultramarins
monsieur le sénateur sur sur l'inflation
en fait contrairement au peut-être à des
idées reçues le niveau d'inflation est
moindre dans les dromes que dans
l'Hexagone nous avions répondu à à ces
éléments là au travers du PLF désolé
j'ai j'ai plus le chiffre d'inflation
mais on vous le mettra si vous si vous
le souhaitez dans le questionnaire mais
oui l'inflation pour autant euh on part
d'un niveau de prix qui de toute façon
était beaucoup plus élevé donc euh euh
autant dans l'Hexagone l'inflation et et
est perçu très réellement autant
malheureusement dans les territoires
ultramarins c'est déjà un phénomène
ancien euh et qui
l'inflation joue un rôle mais on a des
des sujets plus lourds comme l'OC 3 mer
comme le coût des des importations comme
l'absence de de de divers
ification c'est c'est plus ça dans ces
territoires où où le le le sentiment de
vie chère est très très ressenti que
l'inflation en enfin l'inflation
ressenti telle qu'il est ressenti dans
l'Hexagone merci je vais laisser la
parole à l'autre rapporteur George
patient qui est en
visio vous m'entendez
oui parfaitement
oui parfaitement bonjour oui deux deux
deux questions une d'ordre général euh
j'aimerais avoir des précisions sur la
gouvernance de la coopération régionale
je comprends pas très bien il y a un
nombre impressionnant d'intervenants bon
déjà entre le ministère des autres maèes
et le ministère des Affaires étrangères
comment le travail
euh est-il réparti déjà euh avoir des
précisions donc sur la gouvernance de la
coopération régionale et puis
deuxièmement une question qui qui qui
touche l'océan Indien comment peut-on
concevoir l'absence de Mayotte à la
Commission de l'Océan Indien quand on
sait que la France est un gros financeur
l'Europe également et la FD qui joue un
rôle très actif voilà
oui monsieur le sénateur j'ai quelques
mots concernant la la la gouvernance
avec d'abord une précision qui est
importante c'est que ambassadeur
coopération régionale zone atlantique et
l'ambassadeur coopération régionale
Océan Indien ont une lettre de mission
Cigné par le ministre des Affaires
étrangères et par le ministre des des
outremèes et donc on est rattaché à la
fois au ministère des outremèes et au
ministère des des Affaires étrangères ça
permet aussi de faire le de faire le
lien
évidemment après moi je dirais que il y
a des instances qui se sont développer
c'est dans le le respect des compétences
de chacun vous avez les compétences de
l'État et notamment le fait de mener la
politique extérieure sous la légide et
la coordination du du ministère des
Affaires étrangères bien entendu vous
avez des collectivités qui dans leur
domaine de compéten ont les possibilités
d'agir à à l'international et comme vous
le savez c'est vrai qu'avec la loi de
2000 et la loi de 2016 les dromes et pas
uniquement les collectivités du
Pacifique ont qui des compétences
internationales que n'ont pas les les
régions métropolitaines notamment celle
de signer des accords de coopération
avec les États étrangers si elle le elle
le souhaite he donc on a on a vraiment
les compétences de l'État d'un côté en
en politiques extérieures qui sont
traditionnelles qui sont bien
établies on a des compétences l'action
internationale des collectivités et pour
les collectivitésom pour les dromes en
particulier des compétences nouvelles a
appliquer en particulier effectivement
la loi leschimie de de 2016 euh deux
autres éléments de gouvernance à mon
avis qui sont important c'est pour
travailler ensemble dans le respect
toujours des compétences de chacun c'est
d'abord le fait que les les ambassadeurs
chargés de la coopération régionale sont
aussi chargés d'organiser les
conférences de coopération régionale et
pour le le la région antiguyane comme
vous le savez il y a une conférence de
coopération régionale à peu près chaque
année hein depuis depuis 20 ans la
dernière était en Guadeloupe au mois de
mars dernier il y en avait pas eu
pendant 3 ans et demi à cause du du
covid et la prochaine sera pour la
première fois à Saint-Martin en en avril
prochain là c'est vraiment un moment
c'est une instance prévue par la loi
mais c'est un moment de dialogue entre
le l'état service de l'État préfet
ambassadeur sous la la présidence en
général du ministre délégué chargé et
les outremires les collectivités les
élus et les acteurs publics et privés de
la de de la coopération ce qu'on a fait
également au au niveau des des
ambassadeurs c'est une plateforme de
coopération régionale c'est qu'on fait
des réunions vidéos dans le cas
antiguyan c'est une réunion vidéo tous
les 2 mois à peu près avec les les
agents des préfectures qui sont chargés
des dossiers de coopération
régionale les services des collectivités
chargé de la coopération régionale et
nos conseillers culturels et de
coopération dans dans la dans la région
hein Caraïb euh plateau des des Guyanes
ça c'est vraiment une instance d'échange
d'information et de de concertation euh
entre nous et puis pour l'océan Indien
ça existe aussi avec une forme un peu
différente et enfin mais je pense qu'on
reviendra là-dessus dans la discussion
il y a la mesure 54 du sium ça c'est une
mesure importante qui demande euh qui
nous demande de réfléchir maintenant
pour mieux associer les collectivités
d'outremer en fait les dromes euh à la
politique extérieure de l'État par
bassin voyez là il faut trouver une
articulation d'où cette idée que que moi
je trouve excellente de proposer des
stratégies de bassin entre l'État et les
les collectivités pour avoir je dirais
une une une vision et et une action euh
concerté par par zone je pense que si on
arrive à faire ça ce serait une vraie
avancée monsieur le sénateur peut-être
sur la sur Mayotte alors pour vous dire
que effectivement ça fera la transition
avec ce que vient d'indiquer mon mon
collègue concernant la gouvernance la
coopération régionale notre dans l'océan
Indien la prochaine conférence de
coopération
régionale se tiendra à Mayotte et se
tiendra en fait au au moment
ou par ailleurs à Mayotte pour la
première fois le forum économique des
îles de l'Océan Indien se se tiendra ça
c'est pour pour vous dire que que
Mayotte participe en fait déjà à un
certain nombre de cadres
régionaux notamment dans le domaine
économique donc par Cap business Océan
Indien et donc ce forum économique desî
également en matière jeunesse et sport
avec deux organisations notamment la
Commission Jeunesse et Sport de l'océan
Indien qui organise les jeux des jeunes
et aussi donc dans le cadre du mouvement
sportif la euh la conférence qui
organise les les Jeux des îles à la
Commission de l'Océan Indien vous savez
que nous avons besoin du consensus de
tous les États-membres donc vous
connaissez la situation nous avons
depuis 2019 en fait progresser sur un
certain nombre de domaines pour lesquels
Mayotte est euh et les intervenants et
acteurs depuis Mayotte sont euh parties
prenantes dans des programmes dans le
contexte de la COI euh donc c'est euh en
progrès et bon voilà on c'est un sujet
sur lequel nous nous travaillons euh
étroitement donc avec l'ensemble de nos
partenaires euh de la de la COI et je
voudrais ajouter que nous par ailleurs
donc il y a la la conférence de
coopération régionale et cette
gouvernance donc qui inclut pleinement
Mayot j'ai évoqué le programme Interreg
et les et les les les programme européen
je voudrais ajouter que nous nous
travaillons aussi en entre l'État et et
et et maot et le Conseil
départemental sur un renforcement de la
coopération de l'appui pour aider euh
Mayot et les les cadres en charge de la
coopération régionale euh a renforcer
leur leur connaissan leur spécialisation
sur les sujets de politique régional et
de coopération internationale et donc il
y a un certain nombre d'actions que nous
avons mené et préparé avec avec Mayotte
et en en en parfaite coordination
interministérielle et et en particulier
avec la la entre ministère de l'Europe
les affaires étrangères et et le
ministère chargé des outromèes et la et
la dgom euh donc il y a comme je l'ai
évoqué Mayot dispose d'atout important
et d'un potentiel à développer je
voudrais signaler que des les liaison
aérienne de Mayotte avec les pays de la
région se développent les
coopérations comme je l'aiindiqua avec
nos voisins non seulement avec les îles
voisines comme Madagascar entre Mayot et
Madagascar mais aussi Mayotte et euh la
Tanzanie et le Mozambique se développe
et je voudrais signaler quand en matière
de
soutien pour l'attractivité économique
donc nous avons effectivement avec mon
collègue Roland Dubertrand un un travail
en commun dans le contexte du du du sium
comité interministériel de autromèes sur
la la mesure ne9u donc sur les les
stratégies commerciales et et nous nous
nous développons en fait la des des
propositions aussi de diplomatie
économique comme nous disons he pour
soutenir nos nos outresm et et je
voudrais signaler que les les
entreprises des entrepreneurs Maora sont
déjà partie prenantes d'action qui sont
menées dans la région et je voudrais
rappeler un événement qui s'était tenu
en 2023 notamment à Maputo au Mozambique
avec donc le team France Export et et
des entrepreneurs Maurais et
réunionnais dans ce pays avec fort qui a
un fort potentiel de renforcement de nos
coopération merci donc je vais laisser
la parole à notre collègue tar
rich merci madame la Présidente bonjour
à tous désolé pour ce retard un peu
neigeux ce matin euh je je me permettrai
de revenir un peu plus sur effectivement
cette dans le prolongement de ce qu'a
dit George patient sur cette
problématique de diplomatie non pas en
outrem mais des outremè et il me semble
qu'il reste une partie du chemin à faire
je crois que beaucoup a été fait
évidemment parce que sur les les 10
dernières années il faut reconnaître
qu'il y une certaine progression dans
dans
l'association des territoires mais ne
pensez-vous pas par exemple que le fait
de placer des conseillers diplomatique
auprès des préfets plutôt qu'auprès des
exécutifs locaux euh n'est pas encore un
petit frein à cette diplomatie avec et
par les outremes plutôt que en outrem
parce que nous nous mitons bien entendu
euh pour une coopération décentralisée
pas forcément uniquement déconcentrée et
et dans quelle mesure est-ce que vous
pensez que ce chemin est encore euh
réalisable ou alors il contredit un
certain nombre de principes ou euh
risque deevenir à une politique
nationale en la matière mais je pense
qu'il est important qu'on puisse au sein
de cette délégation sans tabou évoquer
ces sujets
euh on a pu aussi entendre hier dans le
cadre du groupe d'armitié avec les îes
du Pacifique les agents de laafd
notamment les personnes en charge euh du
Pacifique pour le coup euh et et on voit
bien aussi que du côté de la FD il y a
une volonté et des instructions très
certain d'une approche par bassin et et
d'une stratégie à développer ce qui
amène à mon deuxième thème dans quelle
mesure est-ce que les conférences
régional pourrait associer davantage en
amont les collectivités au côté de laed
et au côté de vous Messieurs les
Ambassadeurs pour
pouvoir on va dire participer à la
définition et c'est ce que vous évoquez
monsieur Dubertrand en amont donc des
des stratégies régional et non pas
simplement dans le respect des
compétences qui ont été confié à nos
collectivités récemment simplement
vérifier une concordance Infiné avant
qu'elle soit conclue
définitivement je m'explique j'ai le cas
dans le Pacifique lorsqu'il y a eu des
discussion sur le câble qui partait en
coopération avec la Nouvelle-Zélande les
Samois et qui partait donc sur ce
côté-là du Pacifique pour raccorder la
Polynésie d'une autre manière que celle
qui est aujourd'hui qui était à l'époque
uniquement avec Hawaï euh le
gouvernement de la Polésie française a
pu mener un certain nombre de
discussions mais on a il y a eu quelques
blocages Infiné de part et d'autre
certainement aussi quand je dis de part
et d'aut la part aussi peut-être des des
pays avec lesquels nous avions pu
discuter mais du fait certainement que
ces collectivités n'ont pas été
suffisamment on va dire associé en amont
ou en tout cas il y a pas eu plus de
discussion
stratégique avant d'entamer des
discussions opérationnelles quand on
parle du câble de de financement des
discussions techniques de calibrage et
cetera je sais pas si je suis clair mais
voilà est-ce qu'il y a sur ce chemin que
nous nous identifions à parcourir encore
est-ce qu'il y a des blocages que vous
identifiez est-ce qu'il y a des non sens
éventuellement ou que est-ce que c'est
simplement le sens de l'histoire et un
effet d'apprentissage qui est en cours
et et vous pensez que ça pourra encore
évoluer dans les années qui viennent
voilà merci beaucoup pour vos éclairages
oui merci oui je vais répondre sur la
partie conférence de coopération
régionale parce que je crois que c'est
c'est intéressant
euh pour moi ça ça rentre vraiment dans
dans l'esprit de la mesure 54 du sium
mieux associer l'État et les
collectivités dans l'action extérieure
parce que le mode de préparation des des
des conférences si je prends par exemple
la la ccrag donc la conférence antiguyan
on forme un groupe de travail vidéo
avec animé par l'ambassadeur avec les
préfectures et avec les collectivités et
on parle de
l'organisation matériel de la CCR G on
parle du contenu on parle aussi de ce
qui se passe dans les dans les sessions
et et on a aussi un premier débat sur le
type de recommandation qu'on voudrait
faire ensemble l'idée à la fin de la
ccrag c'est ce qu'on a fait en
Guadeloupe en mars dernier on a on a
abouti à un tableau de 13
recommandations qui étaient des
recommandations communes alors parfois
c'était quand même plus le le le l'État
qui avait la compétence pour appliquer
la recommandation comme par exemple sur
les visas parfois c'était plus les les
les collectivités voire même d'autres
acteurs mais on s'était mis d'accord sur
une Sée de de préconisation donc ça je
pense c'est une bonne méthode il faut
que les conférences de de coopération
régionale continuent à être fait de
manière totalement
concertée après la phase actuelle je
dirais c'est l'idée des stratégies de de
bassin qui vont être proposé au aux
collectivités là c'est pour la
coécriture il faut pouvoir écrire les
stratégies ensemble et puis dans le
cadre de la réflexion sur la mesure 54
je pense qu'il y aura aussi si d'autres
étapes par exemple la question qui peut
se poser entre nous je dis entre l'État
et les collectivités c'est est-ce qu'on
veut faire des conventions sur la
manière dont on sur la règle du jeu pour
travailler ensemble au sein des
organisations régional peut-être que oui
peut-être que c'est nécessaire dans
certains cas peut-être que non dans le
Pacifique il a il y a eu le le le VAD
Mcom par exemple donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'on regarde ensemble les
différents outils et que la la ligne
général comme vous l'avez dit quand même
l'évolution dans laquelle on va c'est
c'est une meilleure association des des
collectivités à l'action extérieure
régionale merci tan a demandé la parole
oui merci merci madame la Présidente je
vais être relativement rapide parce que
les sujets ont été ont déjà été abordés
il y avait peut-être la rapporteur qui
voulait intervenir avant
même par galanterie je je je te passe la
parole c'est gentil merci oui euh je
reviens sur la question de de Stéphane
qui est extrêmement pertinente sur euh
le ressenti euh de de l'inflation et et
on voit bien à la réponse de Madame la
directrice générale adjointe qui a qui a
un malaise il y a un souci euh et et
donc moi je je j'espère euh sur votre
rapport pour euh aller plus loin je
pense qu'il y a un sacré problème
d'indicateur et notamment euh l'INC à
notre maèire on peut en reparler euh il
font un bon travail un travail
formidable mais euh qui mériterait
d'aller encore plus en profondeur et
d'aller voir euh les choses dans dans
leur dans leur profondeur donc sans sans
euh forcément m'opposer à à à la réponse
que vous avez donné il y a un
problème de de d'indicateur et il suffit
de vivre dans ces ces territoires pour
voir que les prix sont intenables ils
sont ils sont intenables en plus quand
vous savez que vous avez à faaire aux
collectivités qui ont le qui sont le
plus qui sont les plus pauvres il faut
faut dire les choses de de la France
voilà le cocktail
euh réuni pour euh pour faire quelque
chose de très de très
délétaire mon deuxème mon second point
euh là aussi c'est c'est suite à
l'intervention de de George j'ai entendu
les réponses par rapport à la COI
euh mais nous ne pouvons pas nous en
contenter maot demande à être membre de
la de la COI quand on sait que si ce
n'est pas la France c'est l'Europe qui
finance le fonctionnement de la COI il
est scandaleux que sous prétexte
euh de de d'une politique poste colonial
mené que continue à mener les les
Comores les Comores font pression pour
euh euh que Mayot ne n'intègre pas ces
ces instances c'est bien d'y participer
et merci pour les efforts parce que
effectivement l'association les
participations euh n'étaient pas
d'actualité euh forcément jusqu'à il y a
très peu mais nous voulons que nos
jeunes et bien fassent des compétitions
avec leur drapeau le blanc rouge nous
nous sommes fiers d'être français nous
aimerions que la Marseillaise risonne
lorsque nos gamins euh ont ont ont des
des médailles et non pas simplement
faire les choses en catimini et avoir
honte de de Mayotte Mayotte mérite sa
place à part entière dans ses instances
régionales en
plus et et je ne je ne fais pas de
comparaison avec avec la Réunion euh qui
est effectivement le vaisseau amiral
comme comme vous avez dit de la de la
zone mais lorsque vous regardez le
positionnement géographique Mayot et sur
le canal de Mozambique c'est là où passe
tous les bateaux euh pour l'instant les
outils les empêchent de de passer un peu
plus plus haut mais mais c'est c'est
c'est scandaleux que ce positionnement
géographique et stratégique ne puisse
pas pleinement profiter à cette
collectivité qui traverse des problèmes
insurmontables et sortir euh de ce
cercle vicieux pourrai grandement
contribuer à aider mayod à à à régler à
régler ses problèmes donc nous
reconnaissons les effort fait mais c'est
insuffisant il faut aller plus loin
maotte un département à part entière et
non pas le satellite de je ne sais
quelle autre
collectivité peut-être juste un pointou
monsieur le sénateur je je voulais parce
que j'ai pas j'ai pas pu le mentionner
précédemment mais effectivement dans
dans dans notre discussion et sur les
points que vous évoquez
euh et qui sont tout tout à fait bien
pris euh je voudrais mentionner pour
pour l'information de tous mais vous
avez vu les les informations lors euh de
la visite euh de la première ministre à
la à la fin à la fin 2023 mais je
voudrais rappeler euh le courer qui
avait été adressé à Madame Colona hein
le donc d'octobre 2023 concernant euh un
déplacement à l'ONU en vue de défendre
devant la communauté internationale le
choix historique du maintien de la
souveraineté française sur Mayotte et
donc je voudrais rappeler que dans son
courrier en réponse daté du 30 novembre
2023 la ministre l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères Catherine Colona
assuré son soutien aux élus nationaux et
territoriaux de Mayotte et indiqué avoir
demandé à la représentation permanente
de la France auprès de l'Organisation
des Nations Unies à New York de leur
apporter tout l'appui nécessaire à
l'organ isation de ce
déplacement
merci merci tan et je j'assure les
maoura de mon soutien à titre personnel
et je ne doute pas au titre de la
délégation à la situation et aux
revendications de de Mayotte pour être
pleinement reconnu comme un territoire
français dans dans la zone je vais
laisser la parole donc à Jacqueline
stage Brig rapporteur puis après Lana et
enfin sad qui a demandé
je vais essayer de faire très court
parce que le temps est cont euh juste
deux trois petites réflexions suite aux
différents exposés qu'on fait ce matin
euh moi je me demande quand même parce
que vous avez tous en tout cas madame
précisé que il y avait un degré
insuffisant au niveau de la coopération
régionale moi je me pose la question de
savoir s'il y a pas aussi un
problématique de de complexité parce que
quand à vous écouter c'est quand même
c'est ça pas enfin voilà moi j'ai un
regard neuf hein puisque c'est aussi
pour ça que ça m'intéresse je trouve que
quand même c'est un côté extrêmement
complexe et compliqué quand même et que
quand on est élu local ça do pas être
simple de s'y retrouver sincèrement donc
peut-être il y a-t-il des points
d'amélioration dans dans cette espèce de
d'organisation complexe voilà
après effectivement je pense queil
faudra que nous on analyse peut-être
plus voilà c'est le le le temps qu'on va
se donner pour essayer de comprendre ses
freins à cette opération régionale qui à
titre personnel me semble essentiel pour
le développement de ces territoires
vraiment je pense que la complexité doit
expliquer aussi le retard prix euh et en
ce qui concerne le bassin moi je
m'occupe de l'Atlantique et donc mais
mais ça ne concerne pas que ce bassinlà
je trouve étonnant que ce matin on nit
pas eu une espèce de réflexion ou
d'objectif sur l'emploi et la formation
euh on sait que dans ces îles il y a
beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de jeunes
qui ne sont pas fort
beaucoup de jeunes qui ne travaillent
pas et c'est aussi l'une des difficultés
de nos territoires de C de ces petits
bouts de France à travers le monde et je
trouve que ça devrait il me semble être
un sujet
prioritaire pour donner un
peu de l'espoir et un avenir pour
certains jeunes dans ces territoires et
on en a pas du tout parlé ce matin et je
pense que au niveau de cette coopération
régionale l'remire ça devrait être il me
semble il y en a plein mais il me semble
une
priorité alors sur la sur la complexité
je vous je vous rejoins euh euh
complexité qui peut qui peut
être être lié aussi aux outils européens
notamment interreèg pour lesquels les
collectivités n'arrivve pas toujours à
s'emparer de toutes les opportunités
d'interrèg donc pour cela le ministère
de des outremèes déploi des aides à
l'ingénierie au travers de ses
partenaires alors c'est une action sur
le temps un peu trop long par rapport on
aimerait bien avoir un une action
immédiate mais il faut un peu laisser le
temps à chaque programmation aux acteurs
de se fa de de s'y associer euh sur
l'emploi et la formation bien évidemment
c'est l'une des priorités euh ils sont
dans chacun déclinés dans chacun des
fonds si vous voulez oui vous préciserez
c'est c'est euh et ça passe même la
coopération régionale enfin il y a il y
a c'est massif l'action du Gouvernement
sur l'emploi et la formation des jeunes
pour qu'ils restent dans les territoires
pour une fois formés ils en fassent
partir les territoires enfin s'ils
veulent partir bien évidemment pas de
difficulté mais qu' ne soit pas obligé
d'en partir faute faute de ressources
donc ça fait partie oui des très grandes
priorités du ministère
oui sur ce thème emploi formation dans
le contexte antiguyan c'est un thème qui
est très lié qui est connexe avec la la
mobilité des jeunes ENF en tout cas qui
a été abordé comme ça par exemple il y a
un projet interrè s'appelle élan qui
permet de favoriser pour la Martinique
la Guadeloupe Saint-Martin
saint-barelémie les flux étudiants
scolaires apprentis stagiair enseignant
avec la région hein alors vous avez ça
peut aller du simple l'échange scolaire
de de une
semaine à la formation des des des
étudiants dans dans les deux sens dans
les universités et aussi la formation
professionnelle donc ça c'est un outil
moi j'espère que élan ça c'est élan 1
sur le programme
2014 2020 j'espère que dans le nouveau
programme Interreg hein il y aura aussi
un projet élan parce que ça me paraît
être un des outils pour faire de la
coopération formation justement dans
dans la
région Mame la sénatrice pour le l'océan
Indien en complément c'est un peu
similaire mais il y a des des choses
nouvelles aussi propre à cette région on
a l'équivalent du programme élan c'est
le programme
réunion et mais qui va maintenant aussi
s'articuler avec un nouveau programme de
la Commission de l'Océan Indien soutenu
par lafd et qui entre maintenant dans
une phase un peu opérationnelle avec la
crés une une phase d'étude des des
bassins d'emploi et des capacités de
formation professionnelle donc un
programme qui va être dédié à la
mobilité et formation professionnelle
spécifiquement pour voir et donc entre
toutes les îles de du sud-ouest de
l'océan Indien et ça sur la base
d'études qui ont été mené directement
avec le le tissu économique des
différentes îles de voir où il y a des
besoins euh dans où l'employabilité peut
être particulièrement relevée et les
capacités d'accueil de stagiaires et de
de jeunes en formation professionnelle
donc pour renforcer les échanges et ça
c'est donc première remarque on va
entrer dans une phase opérationnelle
parce que maintenant avec un soutien
supplémentaire de l'AFD il va y avoir
une une unité une préfiguration d'un
d'une équipe permanente donc qui qui
travaille en lien avec tous les les
États de la région qui va se mettre en
place et ça peut se se compléter avec
les les la politique d'outremè les les
le passeport et le les les soutiens de
laad notamment enfin donc une
articulation entre les deux je voudrais
signaler qu'en matière de d'enseignement
supérieur la Réunion développe des
relations de plus en plus diversifiées
notamment avec des pays comme l'Inde et
le l'Australie il y a un campus
franco-indien don l'Université de la
Réunion est un partenaire clé en matière
de biosanté et il y a d'autres
possibilités qui vont être développées
et je voudrais ajouter que pour défendre
l'emploi dans nos outr mers il y a
effectivement rien de telle aussi que la
promotion des
entreprises de la Réunion et de Mayotte
dans leur environnement j'ai évoqué un
exemple de diplomatie économique mais je
voudrais mentionner que justement j'ai
j'ai évoqué le forum économique des îles
mais dans le contexte de l'oraa donc
avec les 23 pays et donc l'Inde
l'Australie l'Afrique du Sud notamment
il y a un forum des affaires et que qui
est maintenant redynamisé par tous les
les parties prenantes dans cette
organisation et qui va tenir des des
forats et aussi des qui va intégrer la
la tech donc nous je veux dire on a la
Réunion la première capitale frenchtech
des Outremers he qui a accueilli
d'ailleurs toutes ceseses ces
partenaires des autres outremers
récemment en novembre pour les outre
mers Tech Days et en fait la tech dans
l'océan Indien en lien aussi avec les
les cluster ou les les pôles de
compétitivité plus largement métropole
et outreem réunis hein selon les sujets
vont être pleinement associés à ces
forums d'affaires et et euh et donc
c'était très intéressant aussi lors des
outreem tech day de rencontrer des
entrepreneurs euh de Nouvelle-Calédonie
ou des Antilles présents à la réunion et
intéressés éventuellement par ce forum
des affaires avec l'Inde et l'Australie
hein et donc ça on va constituer une
équipe France Océan Indien ou France
plus largement mais avec forte présence
des outremèes et avec la région avec le
Conseil régional de La Réunion qui est
pleinement partie prenante aussi pour
cette stratégie économique et donc on va
voilà ça ça fait partie aussi voà de ces
organisations régional et ce potentiel
qui aura des répercussions et nous
l'espérons effectivement en terme
d'emploi dans nos
outremes alors étant contraint par le
temps je vais proposer aux collègues de
poser leurs questions en étant très
concis et je vous proposerai après
quelques minutes pour répondre donc
Saï oui merci madame la Présidente je
vais être vraiment très concis d'abord
je m'associe à au propos de mon collègue
tan sur ce qu'il a dit et j'ai une
question euh nous sommes Rupe Mayotte et
la Réunion vous avez dit comment se
fait-il que on ne peut pas à Mayotte
importer des produits de la réunion sur
Mayotte justement pour lutter contre la
viich chère euh
2è question c'est concernant vous avez
parlé de deux projets structurant et
vous avez parlé de sécurité et sûeté
maritime pouvez-vous préciser de quoi il
s'agit parce que avec la problématique
de l'immigration est-ce que c'est
contenu là-dedans et qu'est-ce que vous
avez prévu et
3è question précision que je voudrais
avoir vous avez parlé de deux projets
structurant mais vous n'avez pas parlé
du projet gazier de
Mozambique avec Total alors que Mayotte
est partie prenante dans cette euh dans
ce grand projet de euh l'ocen indien
donc voilà mes trois questions que je
voudrais merci
Lana merci madame la Présidente bonjour
à tous Depuis euh le début de la réunion
j'écoute euh avec beaucoup d'intérêt ce
qui est dit par nos
invités ce qui a été fait il faut le
reconnaître il faut dire merci mais il y
a encore beaucoup à faire euh dans nos
territoires
Arem ma question euh vient dommage il
est pas là celui qui représente le
Pacifique comme par hasard elle est
absente c'est ça he madame la Présidente
elle est anoua
mais enfin
euh vous avez évoqué le sujet euh de
l'Indo-Pacifique moi ça fait 3 ans ou 4
ans peut-être que j'entends parler euh
de cette
euh de ce sujet sur l'indoppacifique
mais en tant que élu et même je de poser
la question à mon collègue sénateur nous
n'avons jamais été associé on sait même
pas de quoi on parle quelles sont les
déclinaisons de cette stratégie
indopacifique ça veut dire quoi pour
nous élu du Pacifique c'est quoi
stratégie Indo Pacifique ma deème
question sous l'égide du maire de
rapanoui c'est-à-dire île de Pâque un
grand se tiendra sur l'île de pâqu au
mois d'avril où tous les petits États du
Pacifique sont invité sur la
problématique de la pollution plastique
dans l'océan
Pacifique ma question moi j'irai en tant
que parlementaire de la Polynésie
puisque j'ai été
invité ma question quel
serait
conditionnel la position de la France
quand je dis de la France du ha
commissaire ou du représentant de l'État
dans la zone voilà madame la Présidente
pour commencer pour démarer l'année
Éveline bonjour à tous merci madame la
Présidente
eu je vais commencer mon propos par le
cyclone
Béal et vous l'avez mentionné et je
salue la réactivité euh de de l'État euh
pour pour porter secours pour être au
côté des acteurs à la fois euh les les
institutions mais aussi euh tout le
monde économique à la Réunion et euh et
les différents services de secours euh
aujourd'hui l'heure est à la au bilan et
à la reconstruction à la Réunion et donc
euh vient la question du coup sur un
territoire frappé on l'a dit de façon
structurelle par la vie chère euh benah
voilà encore une fois finalement il y a
effectivement vous l'avez mentionner le
fond de secours aux outremèes mais
malgré tout ce sont des fonds qui ne
sont pas inépuisables or euh
or avec
le l'inflation la vie chère euh et et
les
coûts qui augmente pour le le fret du
fait des différents conflits mondiaux et
des crises qui touchent le monde entier
donc notre territoire nos territoires
ultramarins sont
frappés j'ai envie de dire doublement
quelque part et et pour le coup même si
les collectivités sont aidées ce sont
quand même nos collectivités qui vont
devoir payer pour la reconstruction ces
coûts sont importants parce que nous
sommes une île à l'autre bout du monde
et et vient la question du coup de la
coopération régionale de cette
coopération décentralisée qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce que c'est finalement une
coopération vraiment décentralisée
puisque vous l'avez dit il y a la
question diplomatique et puis il y a
aussi la question du développement
économique de nos de nos régions et les
deux sont pilotés différemment il y a
des instances où on se réunit et on
établit ensemble des
stratégies mais on n'est pas à l'abri
des crises des cyclones et cetera en
fait des situations de crise finalement
et et comment on on y répond mais sur le
long terme dans les questions qui vous
ont été transmises sur la Réunion il est
aussi question
euh de ligne de ligne régional et et de
cet essort le collègue de maotte
souligne et comment se fait-il que ça ne
soit pas un axe de développement de la
France que de faire collaborer
travailler et et et et se développer de
territoires français dans l'océan indien
ça c'est un vrai sujet et euh je reviens
sur la question diplomatique
euh une région euh d'outre m ne peut pas
rivaliser avec des puissances telles que
la Chine ou l'Inde d'un point de vue
économique il y a besoin du soutien euh
de la France pour mettre en place euh
des outils de développement que ce soit
des outils aériens pour des liaisons
aériennes ou des des liaisons maritime
c'est un vrai sujet et il nous faut
exister euh en tant que pays euh dans ce
dans dans dans dans nos dans nos océans
finalement et un dernier sujet euh là
c'est plus plus spécifique sur la
Réunion la loi notre effectivement
permet au territoire euh de de répondre
et et de s'adapter aux règles nationales
et aux contraintes euh pour s'adapter
justement aux spécificités locales et
aux
contraintes locales pour la Réunion vous
le savez il y a une exclusion comment
est-ce que vous le voyez quel impact
cela a sur les possibilités et le le les
potentialités que que que que ont les
territoires vous l'avez dit La Réunion
est le vaisseau amiral mais comment
est-ce que ça pourrait être sans ce
frein
constitutionnel merci donc nous arrivons
presque au terme de de de cette première
audition je vais laisser la parole à
Audrey et euh Victorin Laurel qui
souhaite aussi intervenir en leur
demandant d'être vraiment vraiment très
concis oui je je je vais être brve
puisque beaucoup de choses ont été dites
et et et et je m'associe à ce qui a pu
être euh posé comme question par mes
collègues euh moi je voudrais revenir un
petit peu sur euh les les les relations
commerciales dans les bassins régionaux
et demander finalement com quelle
stratégie pour mettre en place ces
stratégies effectivement c'est complexe
cependant nous avons là je pense et vous
l'aviez dit et vous pensez que c'est une
une très belle idée et peut-être une
solution effectivement ça peut-être de
l'évier
d'unun d'un point de vue économique dans
mon enfance moi je mangeais du bœuf du
boswana je mangeais du riz de Madagascar
et aujourd'hui avec les nouvelles normes
cela n'est plus possible si on mutualise
on peut même agir sur l'effet de serre
si on on on mutualise raccourcit les
distances on peut même agir sur le
pouvoir d'achat et sur la cheté de la
vie en matière de santé également
lorsque l'on évoque la Réunion vaisseau
amiral donc moi moi j'ai une pensée très
solidaire pour Mayot qui est dans une
position stratégique et qui mériterait
d'avoir elle-même toute sa place à côté
du vaisseau amiral mais d'un point de
vue santé comment souhaite-on quelle va
être la manière de la France de faire
rayonner d'un point de vue santé dans le
bassin régional son action sur le le CHU
de la Réunion alors qu'on ne lui donne
pas les moyens de le faire à la Réunion
il nous manque beaucoup de de
spécialités donc comment faire rayonner
la stratégie santé de la France dans
l'OC indien comment devenir attractif
face à ces autres pays on reçoit les
Malgaches on reçoit les Mauriciens on
reçoit toutes cette personnes de la zone
de l'océan Indien et donc ça peut être
un atout véritable et donc il faudrait
que cette stratégie se développe mais
réellement singulièrement pas que ce
soit normatif pas que ce soit ascendant
pas que ce soit décidé d'ailleurs les
atouts des uns et des autres doivent
nous permettre de singulariser nos
stratégies donc je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'on puisse le faire rapidement merci
et je on terminera par Victorin en lui
demandant une
minute on ne t'entend pas
malheureusement Victor
ouais bon bonjour à à tous je me suis
levé tôt 5h du matin et c'est grâce à
vous puisque c'était prévu pour 4h du
matin ou même 3h du matin et donc merci
pour cette faveur bon comme j'arrive en
dernier je je vais adresser probablement
des questions écrite euh à la délégation
et à la dgom et si j'avais avant de
poser deux ou trois question un
sentiment émettre il faut sortir du
verbal euh ça fait moi 20 ans hein que
j'entends à peu près les mêmes choses
décliner par les uns et les autres il y
a de la bonne volonté c'est une évidence
mais on répète les mêmes choses hein
dans les conférences régionales euh la
seule chose qui marche c'est là où il y
a de l'argent pour être clair
c'est-à-dire intérg euh ou le dossier
Amazonia en en Guyane c'est là que ça
marche et et si on veut ex 2è avis euh
il faudrait faire un relevé un focus
thématique par exemple qu'àton fait
comme vient de le dire
audre en coopération
sanitaire en tourisme sanitaire quels
sont les obstacles qu'àon fait et c'est
une question en matière de coopération
policière judiciaire militaire attend
aujourd'hui et ça fait 20 ans que
j'entends ça et c'est y a quelques
semaines j'entends qu'on va nommer des
magistrats de liaison on a échoué depuis
toujours pour installer des officiers de
liaison à à à la Dominique au sud de la
Guadeloupe à saintelucie je pose la
question à la DG om peut-on nous dire
aujourd'hui après autant d'années
d'exécution depuis 2007 et c'est
Monsieur Sarkozi qui était venu en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique il était
alors ministre de l'Intérieur et
candidat à la présidence de la
République on a signé des conventions de
réadmission avec la Dominique on n'
jamais eu un bilan on a signé des
conventions de réadmission avec
Sainte-Lucie il y a pas de bilan j'ai dû
attendre 2 ans euh pour avoir copie de
ces conventions puis surous avoir
pouvons-nous avoir ces conventions un
bilan combien de personnes en situation
irrégulière en Guadeloupe en Martinique
ont été renvoyé par exemple en Haïti ou
à
Saint-Domingue comment comment ça se
passe comment a-t-on pu vendre l'île
d'Aves en Guadeloupe Martinique tous
réclam l'île à à à à à la République du
Venezuela on na jamais vraiment été
informé sur ce qui s'est passé en 83 et
après avant et et et après il y a la
manifestement un souci de transparence
ensuite pourez-vous me dire depuis le
vote de la loi de chimie en 2016 combien
d'accords ont-ils été signés quels en
sont les bilans la la manifestement on a
un problème ensuite pourquoi depuis si
longtemps les conventions de
délimitation des territorial n'ont pas
abouti avec l'État français avec la
France avec la République pourquoi il y
a-t-il pas de convention de pêche avec
l'Europe il y a toujours encore des
arraisonnements au nord de la Guadeloupe
entre la Guadeloupe et Antigue on a un
problème pourquoi depuis si longtemps et
depuis la réponse de Gabriel Atal
lorsqu'il était ministre des comptes on
n'est pas revenu à la banque caraïbenne
de développement il y a un problème euh
parce que c'est on avait négligé nos
territoires on a négligé la République
euh d'Haïti il y a des problèmes de
trafic bref il y a Moutte question euh
euh au-delà des instruments qui existent
ils sont nombreux complexes souvent mal
coordonnés ou quand ça se fait c'est
plutôt dans le verbal et donc il n'y a
pas vraiment euh de d'action très
concrète et je partage ce qu'a dit notre
collègue grprit euh on avait euh on veut
faire des conseillers euh euh disons
consulaire euh auprès des préfets euh
moi je m'interroge rappelez-vous on
avait passé accord depuis dou Blas
ministre des Affaires étrangères à
l'époque euh euh les régions ont eu ce
qu'on appelle des chargés de mission
dans les pays de la Caraïb la Région
Guadeloupe alors euh quand j'étais
moi-même exécutif nous avions des
chargés de mission à Québec à Miami en
République Dominicaine au Venezuela euh
bref et bien on pay est puisque on était
logé dans les ambassades il fallait
payer louer la salle payer le téléphone
avoir une assurance et payer un loyer ne
faisait pas grand chose c'était des
subtifs pour aider les ambassadeurs
voilà les questions que je formaliserai
par écrit voilà mer merci beaucoup
Victor mais nous sommes alors je propose
que vous puissiez répondre par écrit à
toutes les questions qui ont été posées
le sujet est vaste d'où euh l'importance
que nous avons la la la le choix de
rédiger une étude par bassin océanique
puisque nous voyons qui vraiment si nous
voulons aller vraiment au fond des
choses il faut travailler par bassin
nous n'aurons pas le temps de en une en
une session de de d'évoquer t tous ces
sujets donc je vous remercie infiniment
j'ai aussi une dernière petite question
vous avez parlé des fonds interg vous
avez parlé aussi euh des des relations
avec les pays étrangers on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé des territoires qui sont
sortis du statut de PTOM à cause du
brexit notamment dans la Caraïbe nous
avons 15 territoires qui sont sortis du
brexit qui ont des pouvoirs de de
développement qui sont limités et on
voit
insidieusement des pays asiatique et
notamment la Chine mettre en œuvre des
politiques de de de
de développement de ces territoires donc
comment la France pourrait aussi grâce à
son influence dans la zone grâce à ses
oututres m conter un peu
ces ce ce l'introspection insidieuse de
de ces pays voilà donc je vous remercie
infiniment pour vos éclairages et nous
attendons un retour une contribution
écrite de toutes ces
problématique sans transition nous
allons enchaîner la deuxème partie de
notre audition qui est consacrée à
l'adaptation des moyens d'action de
l'État dans dans les outremèes donc
comme pour la précédente séquence nous
allons vous laisser la parole pour un
propos liminaire en vous basant
évidemment sur la trame de questions qui
vous a été
adressé Monsieur Philippe Bas
rapporteur s'excuse il a été retenu dans
sa circonscription et et on est vraiment
désolé donc ce sera Victor Lurel en
visioconférence qui fera part de ses
remarques et vous demandera le cas
échéant des des éclairages
complémentaires nos autres par nos
autres collègues aussi pourront demander
la parole je vous laisse la
parole madame la Présidente bon cette
fois-ci je vais être plus concise pour
laisser plus de temps au au au débat
euh on fera si vous si vous en êtes
d'accord également pour répondre à
certaines de vos questions qui sont
assez précises euh l'exercice à
plusieurs voix euh en propos liminaire
simplement pour vous dire euh que nous
partageons le constat que vous faites
que le réflex outremer euh est encore
perfectible nous y travaillons c'est
l'ADN que la direction générale des
outr-em que de faire vivre ce réflex
outr-em mais comme vous le savez la dgom
qui compte aujourd'hui 140 personnels
euh même si elle est très
active ne peut pas embrasser l'ensemble
de la politique des outr-mers et donc on
a besoin que chacun des ministères
euh se préoccupe des outremèes donc bien
évidemment sur ce réflex outremer qui a
été documenté sur cette absence de
réflex outremaire qui a été documenté
dans de nombreux rapports hein dont
certains rapports du Sénat euh a fait
l'objet euh euh d'action de notre part
euh tout d'abord et dernièrement euh
vous le savez le comité interministériel
des outr-mè qui s'est réuni en juillet
dernier a réaffirmé ce besoin du réflex
outremaire euh dès la conception des
politiques publiques euh pour que nous
puissions à la fois sur un point de vue
juridique euh mettre mettre en œuvre les
politiques publiques de manière sécure
sécure mais aussi lorsqu'il nous faut
les concevoir parce que la dgom
coordonne la politique dans les dromes
et l'élabore dans les comes euh autre
exemple nous veillons systématiquement
au moment de la nomination du ministre
chargé des outrir nous rappelons qu'il
lui est important de ne pas avoir
simplement la dgom dans son portefeuille
mais aussi de pouvoir s'appuyer sur
l'ensemble des autres administrations
qui font la politique publique euh et
puis euh un autre exemple euh nous avons
nous nous nous sommes très attachés à ce
qu'il y ait des référents outremè qui
soient nommés dans chacune des grandes
administrations et à animer ce réseau
des des référents pour que très en amont
parce que les outr-emes euh quelquefois
le droit commun leur convient très bien
mais d'autres fois il faut des
adaptations que ces adaptation soit
prise en temps et en heure et enfin pour
aider nos collègues des autres
administrations nous avons fait un
travail pédagogique
euh parce que le droit des outremaires
peut-être complexe pour
euh fiche par fiche politique publique
par politique publique leur expliquer ce
qui relève la compétence de l'État et ce
qui relève des compétences des
différentes collectivités et les
adaptations qui ont pu être faites ici
ou là euh
l'audition estant é en liée à
l'adaptation des modes d'action de
l'État dans les outrmers peut-être deux
information d'actualité sur la manière
dont dont l'état est structuré tout
d'abord vous avez eu en 2022 la création
de la
sous-préfecture de Saint-Georges en
Guyane euh il est assez rare pour le
souligner la création de de de
sous-préfecture et puis en projet qui
sera qui est égal également une annonce
du sium et qui sera concrétisée cette
année la création d'une préfecture de
plein exercice à Saint-Martin pour
accompagner les collectivités de
Saint-Martin et de saint-bartelémi qui
aujourd'hui dont dont le préfet délégué
est aujourd'hui dépendant de la
préfecture de la
Guadeloupe je vous le disais nous sommes
assez n nous partageons le le
constat de de de la de notre capacité
collective à rendre
plus concret le réflex outremer et nous
avons entamé un certain nombre de
travaux ou de réflexions dont je peux
vous faire part et on pourra les
développer si vous le souhaitez
euh tout d'abord peut-être c'est les
modalités de construction des politiques
publiques telles qu'elles ont été faites
au travers des 72 mesures ducium ces 72
mesures du sium euh sont
euh des propositions que les territoires
ont adressé via les préfets euh au au
gouvernement alors toutes n'ont pas été
reprises certaines doivent encore être
travailler mais en tout cas cette
méthode de de demander les propositions
des territoires euh nous nous
continueront à l'adopter pour les
prochaines sessions du SIOM euh autre
chose mais votre c'est votre
questionnaire qui m'y fait songer euh
vous nous avez interrogé sur
l'effectivité euh des consultations des
collectivités d'outrem on vous rejoint
sur le fait que effectivement c'est très
perfectible et nous avons travailler
sur sur peut-être une proposition qui
pourrait vous paraître un petit peu
dissonante où on proposerait de ne plus
consulter comme aujourd'hui en amont de
la loi les collectivités d'outremè
puisqu'on voit que en réalité cette
consultation est assez formelle et
peut-être une fois que la loi qui a a
mis le droit commun et
voté à avoir une habilitation pour
travailler peut-être pendant 18 mois
avec les collectivités pour le temps
qu'elle travaille et qu'elle nous fasse
remonter les adaptations pour avoir des
adaptations politiques c'est pas parfait
bien évidemment puisque on crée un
décrochage
temporel mais ça permet une véritable
association il faudrait pour cela
aussi réviser la Constitution pour
étendre le champ d'habilitation
de l'article
74-1 et et puis revoir peut-être même
faire une forme d'habilitation un peu ad
hoc autre autre priste sur lequel nous
travaillons aussi et pour lequel nous
pourrions saisir le Conseil d'État pour
avoir un avis c'est jusqu'où
pourrions-nous confier aux différents
préfets d'aoutre ma la possibilité
d'éroger aux normes nationales
quand je dis préfet bien sûr au
commissaire également euh on a eu un
précédent au travers du covid où les
préfets ont eu des pouvoirs renforcés
euh donc on voudrait voir avec le
Conseil d'État jusqu'où on peut faire
ses adaptations
euh voilà alors du coup pour le coup
j'étéis beaucoup plus bref voilà voilà
pour les pour les grandes lignes mais
bien évidemment on peut revenir à votre
à votre souhait et bien bien évidemment
on répondra également par écrit à votre
questionnaire mer si si vos collègues
souhaitent
compléter pas pour l'instant donc je
vais laisser la parole à Victorin Lurel
rapporteur
oui merci
madame la Présidente euh
j'ai une petite question d'information
euh je suis arrivé en retard au premier
euh à la première audition je
m'attendais à voir Monsieur mon olivier
Jacob puis-je avoir l'identité de madame
qui vient de parler et ses fonctions
oui bien sûr monsieur le sénateur je
suis Karine de laamar je suis l'adjointe
d'Olivier Jacob et Olivier je n'ai pas
réitéré les excuses de Monsieur Jacob
mais en déplacement à la Réunion son
avion s'est posé avec 3h de retard ce
matin ce qui fait qu'il n'a pas pu être
présent au sein de cette
enceinte bien c'est parce que j'étais
absent début de réunions que je n'ai pas
eu cette euh information merci merci euh
sur la le premier j de question qui vous
a été posé sur l'évolution et
l'organisation des moyens de votre
direction euh avec 140 personnes euh nos
parlementaires députés ou sénateur on a
toujours dit qu'il a là une déicience de
moyen une insuffisance de moyen en tout
cas et qu'il faut renforcer cette DG OM
je rappelle que c'était une simple
délégation à l'époque lorsqu'on a
supprimé les deux directions on l'
transformé en délégation moi-même alors
ministre je l'ai transformé en en
direction
euh j'aimerais vous poser la question
depuis le changement c'est Jose dire de
de de j'allais presque dire de statut ou
ou ou ou ou de Grad du ministère qui
n'est plus un ministère de plein
exercice qui est un ministère délégué je
sais pas quel sera son sort très bienent
quels sont vos rapports avec la tutelle
du ministère de l'Intérieur euh par
exemple en matière de gestion des
ressources humaines euh par exemple en
terme d'instruction des dossiers
euh que devez-vous rendre compte au
ministère euh avec Bercy comment
fonctionne désormais le bureau des
agréments euh comment ça se passe pour
pour ça euh ensuite puisque vous faites
dans la coordination pour les droits h
et carrément dans l'élaboration pour les
les comes
euh comment s'articule les différents
programmes gouvernementaux il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se déclinent et
on a du mal parfois à s'y retrouver par
exemple on avait un plan logement aremer
ça a été ensuite avec Monsieur Caren un
objectif logement autrem nous avions les
plans de relance avec des déclin on
territoriale ensuite on a eu la
trajectoire 5.0 et cetera du Livre bleu
aujourd'hui c'est les 72 mesures du S
comment tout cela
s'articule-t-il comment s'y retrouver
pour les collectivités et quels sont les
bilans qui sont faits et je poserai la
question pour finir cette première série
euh comment c'est articulé la transition
entre les CPER les contrats de plan état
région et les contrats de convergence et
de transformation
voilà merci monsieur le sénateur euh
tout d'abord alors sur les relations
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur vous le
savez la la dgom est est une une
administration de mission avec quelques
quelques euh opération en gestion en
revanche pour tout ce qui est les
fonctions support la dgom dépend du
ministère de l'Intérieur donc
c'est-à-dire que et ça que ce soit
ministre délégué ou de ministre de plein
exercice
euh nous ne nous ne gérons pas les
personnels au quotidien on a une des des
une ressource humaine de proximité pour
le numérique nous sommes ancrés à au
ministère de la de l'intérieur avec la
direction du numérique et ça ne pose pas
de difficulté je pense que nous
profitons même de de la force de cette
grande administration centrale et nous
n'avons pas à la dgom la capacité de
recréer une petite
rche un petit service numérique et je
pense que ce serait pas forcément euh
très pertinent ensuite en terme de de
relation entre le ministre de
l'Intérieur et le ministre délégué euh
j'ai une expérience assez courte puisque
je suis à la dgom depuis depuis 3 mois
aujourd'hui mais le ministre délégué
agit vraiment par délégation du
ministère de l'Intérieur et l'ensemble
des dossiers que vous avez dit par
exemple la défiscalisation et bien et
bien dans le
portefeuille du ministre délégué aux
outr maire ensuite sur l'articulation
des des programmes gouvernementaux et
comment euh l'ensemble des ministres euh
des ministres travaillent au droits des
outremères ben ça ça rejoint un petit
peu le le constat c'est notre travail au
quotidien d'assemblier euh et de faire
que l'ensemble des politiques trouve
leur déclinaison outre mer et pour ça le
sium qui était euh le dernier sium qui
est qui était sous la présidence de la
première ministre a a a permis d'aller
bien au-delà des seuls at bution de la
dgom et avec autour de la table des
ministres des ministres en charge qui se
sont donc intéressés aux
outrmèes en particulier et enfin vous
pardon j'ai j'ai dû oublier certaines de
de vos questions je m'en excuse mais je
pense que vous pourrez nous les reposer
par écrit et sur la transition avec les
les
CCT la l'actuelle CCT a été prolongé
d'une année pour pour arriver à échéance
et les nouveaux sont en cours de
négociation avec les
territoires ah d'accord
ok ok
bien est-ce que je laisse d'autres
collègues poser des questions ou je
continue comme tu es le rapporteur si tu
as d'autres questions à poser et puis
après je donnerai la parole au collègues
oui ou sur le volet nouvelle
organisation décentralisée et
déconcentré de l'État
euh pourriez-vous m'éclairer
sur l'évolution de ces rapports là et de
l'action de l'État depuis les
modifications et les simplifications
organisationnelles en Guyane et en
Martinique est-ce que ça s'est simplifié
est-ce que ça a été modifié
euh avec des
interlocuteurs désormais est unique
est-ce plus fluide que dans les régions
euh
monodépartementales deuxème chose
comment s'organise la présence de l'État
euh dans les territoires étendus comme
la Guyane ou multiinsulair comme la la
Guadeloupe et la
Polynésie
française 4e point euh quel bilan du
déploiement de l'activité des espaces
français servic
[Musique]
euh trans service ou des bus services
dans les outoutremers j'ai Mo savoir
comment l'État seorganiseil enfin est-ce
que comment l'État euh répond-il aux
inégalités d'accès service public aux
appels à projets liés au phénomène
croissant de dématérialisation
administrative sur des territoires
marqués par l'électronisme voilà dans ce
volet là quelques comp ment
d'informations que nous aimerions
avoir monsieur le sénateur il y a un
certaines de de vos questions sur
lequell peut-être il nous faudra euh
revenir plus tard puisqu'elles ne sont
pas dans le périmètre de la dgom je
pense notamment à France service pour
lequel on demandera les éléments pour
vous les apporter à à la NCT ou en tout
cas on les a peut-être mais je les ai
pas je les ai pas en tête là-dessus euh
sur les la présence de l'État et
l'organisation de l'État je vous disais
en Guyane notamment compte tenu du fait
que c'est la préfecture la plus étendu
de France puisque c'est le département
le plus étendu de France donc on a créé
une une nouvelle sous-préfecture et la
la Guyane
est
et la préfecture de Guyane pardon les
services de l'État en Guyane sont
organisé de manière très spécifique
puisqu'ils sont organisés en cinq
directions euh il faudra encore faire un
un bilan euh de cette organisation mais
qui semble donner satisfaction
[Musique]
euh sur la création euh des
collectivités euh de de de Martinique
euh euh est-ce que ça a simplifié euh le
rôle de l'État je pense que euh l'État a
présent un interlocuteur unique au
niveau de la collectivité départementale
il reste l'ensemble des problématiques
avec les communes et les
intercommunalités mais plus que le
nombre d'acteurs peut-être c'est
l'ensemble des problématiques pour
répondre à nos concitoyens qui elles n
n'ont pas disparu du fait de
l'organisation institutionnel de ces
collectivités et sur les services
publics pareil on vous répondra si vous
le voulez bien mais dans un second
temps d'accord euh merci sur les
consultations
euh les collectivités ont souvent le
sentiment et la question vous a été euh
envoyé sur des réformes déjà arbitrées
un sentiment de
tardiveté de rapidité de caracteur un
peu trop artificiel de certaines
consultations comment
concrètement sont organisés ces
consultation sur les projets
d'adaptation des lois des règlements
des normes euh qui est consulté dans
quel délai quel est le le le rôle du
Conseil d'État euh dans ces types de
consultation ensuite vous avez évoqué il
y a un moment les habilitations en
évoquant le 74 je crois tir un pour les
les com et notamment la Polynésie mais
les habilitations qui nous sont
délivré moi-même un président alors j'en
ai fait 20 29 de loi de région
j'appelleis ça comme ça publié au
Journal officiel autant de décret de
région euh je peux vous dire Madame ça
coûte très cher comment améliorer les
habilitations dé livré en vertu de la
Constitution modifié en 2003 comment
améliorer ça un amendement coûte
beaucoup moins cher que demander une
habilitation ça prend beaucoup de temps
il faut de l'ingénierie comment le faire
comment améliorer par exemple aussi et
comment remplacer les appel à projet qui
irite un peu les
élus alors sur les consultations on fera
de voix avec mon collègue Olivier Benoît
alors mais les consultations selon quel
alors d'abord qui les qui consulte
euh c'est soit le secrétariat général du
gouvernement pour les textes de niveau
législatif soit la dgom pour les textes
de niveau réglementaire euh je pense
qu'on on partage votre constat qu'un
certain que de temps en temps les
consultations outremè sont vécues par
certaines des administration comme une
contrainte calendaire alors
que le le ministre demande qu'on aille
vite sur les réformes dire qu'il faut
consulter pendant un mois les
collectivités
d'outrem paraît être
contre-productif donc on on on a on a on
a réfléchi sur sur comment améliorer ça
il y a eu des idées par exemple de
faire une section du cnen du par exemple
qui serait dédié au texte outremire mais
pour être tout à fait tout à fait
honnête avec vous la difficulté que
connaissent les collectivités d'outremè
le cnen le connaît également sur les
textes de valeur législative pour à peu
près les les mêmes contraintes euh
ensuite
pour le Conseil DEAT le Conseil d'État
est vraiment le garant des consultations
outremè il ne se prononce pas tant que
la l'avis de la collectivité ou des
collectivités
sollicité n'a pas été rendu
euh Olivier tu veux compléter je te
laisse tout à fait bonjour monsieur le
le sénateur le Conseil d'État dans la
dans la procédure et garant justement de
de l'effectivité de ces
consultations euh et après donc le le
mécanisme a été rappelé les les
réflexions qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui consistent à envisager soit
une extension de ce délai de
consultation très court aujourd'hui
puisque dans le droit commun on est sur
30 jours en en situation d'urgence il
peut même être réduit à à 15 jours alors
une première piste de réflexion pourrait
de l'étendre envisager un mois et demi 2
mois pour autant comme la la rappelé
Karine de la marche à l'instant le la la
façon dont sont produites les réforme
dont sont préparé les normes euh nous
conduit à penser que tout ça est
relativement irréaliste et qu'on aurait
pas toujours cette faculté en amont euh
d'où la la réflexion un peu inversée qui
a été qui a été présentée tout à l'heure
de réfléchir à un travail d'habilitation
et un travail beaucoup plus nourri
beaucoup plus fourni en lien avec la
collectivité qui permettrait une fois la
loi votée une fois la loi mieux
appréhendée aussi dans sa finalité
puisque le débat par parlementaire
aurait eu lieu de travailler avec les
collectivités à la façon de les
décliner le plus le plus finement en
prenant le mieux en compte les les
enjeux de la collectivité donc ça
rejoint les les habilitations à article
74 et on pourrait aussi imaginer des
mécanismes qui font qu'elles ne
deviennent pas cadues à partir du moment
où les les projets de loi auront été
déposés au
Parlement et puis pardon sur sur les
habilitations là je pense que on on
dépasse euh la question des outresmèes
euh pour pour avoir c'est également les
la les mêmes difficultés qui sont
aujourd'hui observées d'ingénierie
effectivement faire la loi
euh demande une certaine expertise euh
avec euh les propositions de
d'habilitation il me semble que
certaines associations d'élus se
mobilisent euh pour euh mettre leur
expertise euh à l'appui des
collectivités qui ont euh l'idée euh
d'un domaine d'expérimentation ou d'un
domaine d'habilitation puisque en fait
euh sous des vocables juridiques très
distincts et des mécanismes juridiques
distint euh la finalité en tout cas est
très proche
oui
oui oui euh autant les habilitations
données aux élus et aux collectivités
ont pu donner quel quelques résultats
depuis
2009 la et la Martine en tout cas l'ont
utilisé autant on ne sait pas ce que les
préfets ont fait du pouvoir récemment
délégué pour
adapter adapter si je dire les les
normes
euh comment expliquer cette
prudence première chose dans l'action de
l'État deuxè chose puisque le dernier
rapport du Conseil d'État
euh propose de changer de logique et de
passer à ce qu'il appelle la logique de
compliance pour l'efficacité des
politiques publiques et travailler ce
qu'il appelle le dernier kilomètre qu'en
pensez-vous alors monsieur le sénateur
en effet sur le le pouvoir de dérogation
des préfet on n aujourd'hui pas sur un
pouvoir d'adaptation des normes on est
sur quelque chose de assez binaire qui
permet au au préfet d'écarter
l'application d'une norme parce que pour
un motif d'intérêt général dans un champ
de de compéten thématique assez assez
précis et absolument pas sur un un
pouvoir d'adaptation des textes comme on
l' évoqué précédemment alors pourquoi il
est plus utilisé parce que je pense que
dans sa dans son esprit dans sa finalité
il a pas vocation à l'être trop non plus
c'est-à-dire que les normes qui sont là
ont une ont une finalité soit en terme
de sécurité soit enfin il peut y avoir
différentes finalités ce n'est que dans
des cas extrêmement particuliers que le
préfet peut déroger euh on a sur les les
recensements là qui nous qui nous
reviennent de la de la démat au
ministère de l'intérieur on est sur une
vingtaine ou une trentaine
d'applications depuis que ce ce pouvoir
de dérogation a été généralisé c'est à
la fois peu mais ça montre néanmoins que
les préfets se le sont approprié
aujourd'hui et peut-être d'ailleurs que
tout ne remonte plus maintenant en
administration centrale puisque par que
c'est vraiment une une procédure une
procédure déconcentrée alors sur un
pouvoir d'adaptation ça ça peut être en
effet extrêmement intéressant dans le le
champ réglementaire et ça fait partie
aussi des des réflexions qui sont les
nôtres aujourd'hui avec un précédent
dans le casre de la de la crise
sanitaire où les préfets ont pu adapter
la la réponse de l'État par rapport à un
certain nombre de de problématiques
sanitaires de déplacement des personnes
et cetera
où on leur a confié véritablement le le
pouvoir d'adapter les règles nationales
aux spécificités de de leur territoire
donc ça c'est des des choses qu'on peut
retravailler avec avec le Conseil d'État
et qui pourrait en effet dans le cadre
des des réflexions actuelles donner plus
de marge de manœuvre locale et rejoindre
un petit peu la la préoccupation que
vous évoquiez à
l'instant je vais compléter pour vous
dire que cette cette réflexion qu'on
qu'on a nous outre maire sur le pouvoir
de dérogation du préfet également
miroite avec avec des réflexions pour
l'ensemble des des collectivités et sur
les pouvoirs de de dérogation du préfet
aujourd'hui hein tels qu'ils existent
euh je vous renvoie aux travaux de la
délégation des collectivités
territoriales qui je crois l'année
dernière sous la présidence de Madame
Gattel et Monsieur Darnaud a travaillé
ce sujet avec un bilan sachant que au
travers de de ce bilan on a vu que comme
le disait mon collègue c le le le bilan
formel et en de ça de la réalité puisque
certaines demandes de dérogation ne ne
sont pas connues forcément de
l'administration
centrale h
h je vous fais un dernier j de question
je laisserai à mes collègues le soin de
compléter euh on vous a posé la question
sur les appels à projet qui sont pas
trop appréciés a tropire mais je peux
dire aussi dans dans
l'Hexagone on disait par quel méthode
les remplacer on a eu le sentiment en
tout cas je partage ce sentiment là que
il y avait avec les réformes qui ont été
prise la politique conduite par les
gouvernements successifs une tentative
ou une action vécu peut-être
différemment ici ou là mais de
recentralisation alors que avant euh
c'était géré en autonomie soit par les
entreprises soit par les ménages soit
par les collectivités vous reprenez ce
qui s'est euh passé en matière
d'abattement fiscal sur l'IER sur la TVA
NPR sur un certain nombre d'articles et
tout ça devait être REC centralisé au
sein de l'action 4 du programme 138
est-ce que aujourd'hui vous pouvez ne
pas nous répondre tout tout de suite
mais nous fait tenir un bilan de cette
recentralisation de cette reprise
d'écriture au sein de la mission autre
maire qu'est-ce que ça a donné des
années après notamment sur les 100
millions de la TVA NPR où sont-ils
aujourd'hui sur les
sidomes les 20 millions qui devaient
être inscrits dans le budget qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont devenus et comment ont-ils
été
employé quel est le montant de la
politique de réduction de l'abattance
fiscale sur le revenu tout ça ça fait
partie des modes d'action de de de
l'État et en transparence d'ailleurs la
Cour des comptes l'a dit sur le dpt sur
son caractère un peu illisible et et
parfois
incompréhensible comment aujourd'hui
mieux informer les parlementaires sur
l'action de l'État sur les actions
prises euh et et sur la gestion
euh postérieur à ces décisions euh voilà
comment ont été géré euh ces euh euh
sommes là depuis
2017-29 je je me passerai les questions
je vous les envis s'il le faut sur le
FEI sur la plateforme subventia euh où
euh on aimerait savoir comment euh tout
ça se développe conjointement surous la
direction de la dgom et de la direction
euh du euh numérique et sur le fond
outrema l'ancien fond 5.0 créé en 2019
je vous enverrez des questions sur ça
mais pourriez-vous nous dire euh ou
peut-être nous proposer de nous envoyer
un bilan chiffré sur la gestion de tous
ces dispositifs qui ont disparu
recentraliser supprimer une certaine
liberté d'action et d'autonomie laissé à
l'époque aux entreprises aux ménages aux
associations et aux
collectivités monsieur le sénateur bien
sûr on vous enverra le bilan
effectivement on vient d'avoir vos
questions mais on n pas pu on n pas pu
les travailler en amont je pense qu'une
un certain nombre des bilans des
dispositifs fiscaux sont dans les
documents d'information autour du PLF je
vous rejoins sur le fait que le dpt
mériterait d'être d'être travaillé et
refondu pour être plus lisible euh c'est
un projet un petit peu de de longue
annelle mais on vous répondra vraiment
sur sur le bilan des des
dispositifs dont nous vous nous avez
fait la
liste merci madame la Présidente j'en
est fini merci cher Victorin je vais
laisser la parole à audreé
bellim merci madame la Présidente alors
je vais être brève juste vous dire lors
lorsque j'ai entendu votre proposition
dite dissonante euh j'ai j'ai j'ai
failli entendre même qu'il y avait une
révision de la Constitution euh il y a
tout de même cet article 73 al 5 qui
nous posera forcément problème à la
réunion concernant l'adaptation je
tenais à le rappeler et puis euh
évidemment vous passe un message afin
que vous puissiez le dire au plus haut
nous avons à la Réunion donc je l'ai
appris il y a quelques minutes un
millier de réionnais qui est bloqué
actuellement à Maurice puisque air
maurriichus a des problèmes techniques
suite à Béal et donc nous avons un
certain un millier de familles bloqué
soit en zone de transit soit l'aéroport
euh parce qu'il il y a fin de vacances
parfois pas forcément les moyens de
trouver un hébergement d'urgence à ce
moment-là à Maurice on est en pleine
période touristique aussi donc je
voulais également vous faire passer ce
message merci il y a-t-il d'autres
collègues qui souhaitent
intervenir non alors je ah ça ça euh
comme je l'ai toujours dit les nos
territoires sont complètement euh
différent
et comment mettre en place une politique
publique par exemple à Mayotte
lorsque nous arrivons pas à maîtriser la
démographie
euh nous avons bien sûr un taux de de
croissance assez inédit et en même temps
on n'a pas les données exactes dans les
différentes collectivités et ce qui fait
que on passe notre temps à improviser et
en même temps bien sûr la Chambre
régionale de comptte arrive pour nous
contrôler on est accusé des mauvais
gestionnaires alors que euh euh
justement on n'a pas je dirais euh les
dotations qui devaient je dirais euh
nous permettre de mettre en place les
politiques publiques je prends l'école
les écoles à mayillotes c'est tous les
jours qu'il faut construire comme la on
dit que nous avons la plus grosse
maternité d'Europe avec euh 12000
naissances par an né à Mayotte une salle
de classe tous les jours et cetera et
cetera donc euh comment c'est vrai
mettre en place justement C ces
politiques publiques et comment
pourrons-nous les évaluer après face à
cette situation dirait
inédite euh
Éveline merci euh moi je rejoins un
petit peu les euh les questionnements
euh euh enfin la la la question et les
propos de mon collègue euh par rapport à
Mayotte c'est vrai que
je pense que il y a le rôle de l'État
dans les outrmers je crois qu'il faut
aussi l'envisager par bassin parce que
forcément les les les problématiques
qu'on rencontre à Mayotte ne sont pas
les mêmes qu'on retrouve à la Réunion et
pour autant ce qui est fort dommageable
c'est de de devoir regarder depuis
maotte vers l'Hexagone pour trouver des
solutions ou pour la réunion de devoir
regarder vers l'Hexagone pour trouver
des solutions je crois que entre
territoire ultramarin et par bassin on
est on pourrait euh grâce au moyens de
l'État organiser et trouver des réponses
localement c'est le cas pour la question
de l'école c'est le cas pour la
formation c'est le cas pour l'emploi ou
le dynamisme économique et et et comment
comment est-ce que au-delà d'un réflexe
outremer outremer par outremer
territoire par par territoire imaginez
une politique ultramarine où les
outremèes peuvent aussi
euh porter des solutions euh et se
compléter euh par bassin ce qui générit
euh un vrai euh développement circulaire
ce qui euh développerait aussi euh la la
la visibilité de la France en outreem ça
c'est un premier sujet et puis euh
l'autre sujet c'était euh euh je reviens
encore sur sur la la la formation sur
les liens avec les les euh les
territoires voisins
euh encore une fois le rôle de l'État
euh quand est-ce que
le la question des outres maire rejoint
la question diplomatique en fait c'est
enfin c'est peut-être mal posé mal
formulé comme ça mais c'est vraiment un
sujet et comment on en
mesure le le l'impact et comme l'a dit
ma collègue euh encore une
fois comment est-ce que on on on on se
positionne par rapport à cette article
73 et cette alinéa 5
euh parce que effectivement euh chaque
territoire est différent et de par la
loi merci euh je vais clore ces ces
questions avec un certain nombre par
parfois un peu qui concerne dans une
concerne un peu les collectivités
d'outreem donc comment expliquer les
délais d' d'approbation des actes des
collectivités d'utrem pris en vertu de
leur participation aux compétences de
l'État pour Saint-Bart le délai de 2
mois n'a jamais été tenu s'agissant des
sanctions pénales pourquoi ces avis
lorsqu'ils sont opposés ou font des
propositions qui ne ne sont jamais ou
font des propositions ne sont jamais
pris en compte
euh décliner selon moi revient à
considérer que l'adaptation suppose des
délais d'entrée en vigueur dans dans les
autres m qu'est-ce qui empêche
l'administration de se rapprocher des
collectivités en dehors d'une
prescription et qu'est-ce qui freine la
souplesse dans les relations qui
relèvent pourutant du bon sens et
l'histoire de saint martelemi aussi
montre que les élus avaient plus de
contact avec les administrations et que
on constate petit à petit que que ces
ces contacts se se
ferment alors bien pris sur sur l'alerte
sur sur Maurice
euh s'agissant de maotte et de l'effort
de l'État je pense que l'État a répondu
présent ces derniers mois au travers de
la de la crise de l'eau à Mayotte
mais également au travers du soutien
qu'il a pu donner au conseil
départemental de de Mayot le sujet du
recensement est un sujet bien identifié
au sein du ministère des outremèes et
puis l'ensemble de ces questions
pourront je pense alors peut-être pas
l'ensemble de cette questions mais une
partie j'espère trouver une traduction
dans le prochain projet de loi de
Mayotte dont la première ministre a
annoncé le principe en juillet qui
effectivement a été un petit peu décalé
par rapport au aux 6 mois avancés mais
pour
lequel la direction générale des outrm
fera des des propositions à ses
ministres
euh sur le besoin de l'État par bassin
alors je vais vous faire une une réponse
qui va vraisemblablement pas vous
satisfaire totalement mais on a déjà un
l'État est au quotidien bien au travers
des services locaux
euh la direction générale des outr-emèes
a peut-être une spécificité comme
administration centrale euh car elle est
très en contact avec les services locaux
au quotidien donc euh c'est vrai que
l'État l'État c'est d'abord l'état à
proximité euh avec les services
déconcentrés enfin peut-être plus
largement euh sur les différences de
traitement lorsqu'elles sont nécessaires
elles sont toujours possible endroit dès
lors qu'il y a une situation
objective différente qu' est qu' est qui
qui les justifie et pardon j'allais
oublié de répondre à à l'une de votres
questions sur notre notre idée un petit
peu
disruptive de de de proposer de de
supprimer les consultations utromè c'est
bien évidemment pas de les une
suppression sèche c'est le la pression
d'une modalité au profit d'un d'un autre
donc le constat c'est que ces
consultations ne sont pas aussi
effective qu'elle le devrait qu'on
pourrait prévoir un délai après la la
promulgation d'une loi pour permettre
aux collectivités
ultramarines de proposer au gouvernement
des adaptations qui leur paraissent
nécessaires le temps de cette
concertation permettrait peut-être à ce
que des propositions d'une collectivité
soit reprise par une autre et adapté on
laisserait pas 15 jours he pour faire ça
ce serait un travail de fond on pensait
un délai de 18 mois mais il faudrait il
faut pas non plus qu'il soit qu'il soit
trop long et oui il faudrait aménager
l'article
74-1 pour permettre cette habilitation
ad hoc aux collectivités qui ne sont pas
régis par l'article 74 justement et et
faire en
sorte mais ça suppose une révision de la
Constitution on peut pas le faire à
droit constant euh tout à fait et enfin
sur vraiment sur les difficultés madame
la Présidente que vous avez
relevé la faites les nous passer ou
ou refaites-les passer au préfet
délégué éventuellement madame la
sénatrice un petit complément à vos
questions sur des solutions
territorialisées mutualisées
éventuellement je voulais citer
peut-être quelques quelques exemples
déjà un exemple où les régions sont en
première ligne euh pour la gestion de de
crédit il s'agit de la gestion des
crédits européens les régions sont
autorité de gestion à quelques exemples
près par exemple à Mayotte donc la
direction général des outres-mèes se
place en position de de facilitateur
facilitatrice de l'action des régions et
de de en position aussi de d'apporter de
l'ingénierie et aussi de d'aider à la
mutualisation des bonnes pratiques c'est
ce qui a été fait par exemple il y a un
an à la réunion avec un séminaire qui a
réuni toutes les autorités de gestion et
autour de thématiques qui avaient été
choisies avec ces autorités nous avons
essayé de susciter le partage de bonnes
pratiques par exemple un guichet unique
pour pour les porteurs de projets pour
les entreprises en premier lieu donc un
certain nombre de de partages de bonnes
pratiques ont été proposés avec donc
avec une participation très active des
autorités de gestion on peut citer aussi
le logement le logement social les plans
logement ont été évoqués tout à l'heure
par le rapporteur euh et donc là il y a
une un partage très très fort de bonnes
pratiques avec l'ensemble des acteurs
que ce soit les collectivités locales
les acteurs du BTP les acteurs bien sûr
de du logement social les les les
opérateurs en les les les constructeurs
en en particulier et donc cette approche
très territorialisé sera renforcé à dans
le cadre du prochain plan logement le
plan logement 3 qui qui débutera cette
année donc avec un dialogue local
renforcé donc il à la fois le dialogue
local renforcé et puis aussi des
réunions périodiques qui sont organisées
avec l'ensemble de ces
acteurs donc de toutes toutes les
régions d'outremer pour effectivement
mutualiser les bonnes pratiques échanger
sur les aussi les difficultés et les
solutions
possible voilà je voulais juste apporter
ces quelques exemples mais il y en a
d'autres qu'on pourra vous donner par
écrit merci madame Richard donc si nous
n'avons pas d'autres questions je vais
lever la séance merci infiniment pour
votre intervention et nous sommes nous
attendons une contribution
écrite bien entendu merci à
vous